I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everyone.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。
Ho, ho, ho. This is a big episode. It's the Christmas. Christmas episode. It's the Christmas episode, the very first Christmas episode of The Office. Season 2, episode, you know, it's not, we call it the Christmas episode. Yeah, we do. Or Christmas episode, but it is technically called Christmas party. What? Yeah, that's the name of this episode. I don't believe you. I don't believe you. No, I'm kidding. We did. We call it the Christmas episode. We call it the Christmas episode. Even though there were many more, this is the Christmas episode. I have so much to say, I have 12. typed pages today. It looks like you're holding like a mini phone book. I feel like I'm holding a one-act play or something. It's very large. And when I came in today, I will share that I refuse to speak to anyone because I said I was saving it for the mic. And I'm saving it for the mic. She did. I tried to make small talk with her. And she's like, I'm saving it for the mic. I was like,
霍，霍，霍。这一集内容很丰富。这就是圣诞节。圣诞节那一集。这就是圣诞节那一集，《办公室》的第一集圣诞特辑。第二季，第，你知道，不是，我们叫它圣诞集。对，我们会的。或者叫圣诞集，但它真正的名字其实是圣诞派对。什么？对，这就是这集的名字。我不信。我不信。不，开玩笑的。我们真的这么叫。我们管它叫圣诞集。尽管后面还有很多集，但这就是“圣诞集”。我有太多话要说了，我今天写了12页。你看上去好像拿了一本迷你电话本。我觉得我拿的是一出独幕剧什么的。非常厚。而且我今天进来的时候，我要说的是，我拒绝和任何人说话，因为我说我要把这些留到麦克风前再说。我要把留在麦克风前说。她真的这么做了。我试图和她闲聊。而她说，我要把它留到麦克风前。我说，
okay, lady, you do you. I just, I'm just going to tell you, I liked your hair. I, you got little pigtails today and they're real cute. I have plats. What are plats? That's what they say in the U.K. They're like, oh, look at your plots. Oh, yeah, they also call Banks Fringe. I know, I like it. Yeah. I don't know if you notice my side of the table. Totally filled with note cards.
好吧，女士，你随意。我只是，我只想告诉你，我喜欢你的头发。我，你今天扎了两个小辫子，真的很可爱。我有辫子。什么是辫子？英国人是这么说的。他们会说，哦，看你的辫子。哦，对，他们还把刘海叫Fringe。我知道，我喜欢。对。不知道你有没有注意到我这边的桌子。完全堆满了便签卡。
By my side of the table, you guys, I've made a buffet of note cards. Like, I actually have to be aware, like Sam is saying to stay in front of the microphone, because I have so many cards. I'm going to have to slide back and forth. Yeah. Down my buffet. A card. You love a buffet. I love a buffet, baby.
在我的桌子旁，伙计们，我弄了一个便签卡自助餐。就像，我实际上必须注意，就像山姆说的要待在麦克风前面一样，因为我有太多的卡片了。我不得不前后滑动。对。顺着我的自助餐。一张卡片。你太喜欢自助餐了。我喜欢自助餐，宝贝。
Even if it's note card. Give me that Vegas buffet. All right, Christmas party written by Mike Shreys. and directed by Charles McDougall. Here's a synopsis. It's Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Today is the day of the office holiday party. The group originally plans to have a secret Santa gift exchange,
哪怕它是便签卡。给我来那个拉斯维加斯的自助餐。好了，《圣诞派对》由迈克·施雷斯编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔导演。以下是剧情简介。邓德米夫林正在过圣诞节。今天是办公室假日派对的日子。大家原本计划进行神秘老人礼物交换，
but when Michael doesn't like his gift, he turns it into a Yankee swap. This causes a multitude of confusion and hurt feelings, and Michael's solution is then to go out and buy booze, which is against company rules, and to try to get the party back on track. 15 bottles of vodka. That'll do it. Fast back number one, as I've already said, it's our very first Christmas episode.
但当迈克尔不喜欢他的礼物时，他把它变成了一场洋基换宝。这导致了极大的困惑和伤心，迈克尔的解决办法是出去买酒，这违反了公司规定，并试图让派对重回正轨。15瓶伏特加。这招管用。趣事一，正如我刚才所说，这是我们的第一集圣诞特辑。
But we filmed it nowhere near Christmas. No, you never do because you have to stay ahead. So you're always, it's like Christmas and July kind of thing. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah McGreen. Did U.S. cast members ever have Christmas parties or do a Yankee swap? And if so, what was the best funniest gift someone brought? A lot of people also asked if we exchanged gifts as a cast. Not at the holidays.
但我们拍摄的地方离圣诞节十万八千里。不，你们永远不会在圣诞节拍，因为你们必须赶进度。所以总是像七月份过圣诞节那种感觉。嗯，我们收到了萨拉·麦格林的粉丝提问。美国演员们曾有过圣诞派对或玩过洋基换宝吗？如果有，别人带来最好、最搞笑的礼物是什么？很多人还问我们演员之间是否交换过礼物。节日期间没有。
We would do what's called a rap gift, which happens at the end of the season, and we would usually finish filming our seasons in, like, what, April? And then the cast would get together and we'd pool our money, and we would buy the crew. Every member of the crew would get a gift from the cast. And then sometimes cast members would give each other rap gifts. Little individual gifts. Yeah. I did host a Yankee Swap Christmas party, and I did it every day.
我们会搞一种叫杀青礼的东西，发生在季度末，我们通常会在比如四月左右拍完我们的季度？然后演员们会聚在一起凑钱，给剧组买礼物。剧组的每位成员都会收到演员们的礼物。然后有时演员们会互相送杀青礼。小型的个人礼物。对。我确实举办过洋基换宝圣诞派对，而且我连续几年每年都办。
every year for a few years. And I actually want to bring it back. I took a few years off because just, you know, life kids and, you know, stuff like that. Yeah. But I hosted a Yankee swap party every year. Oh, yes, you did. And it was a big party and everyone would come and it got so rowdy. Yeah. My favorite person to have at a Yankee swap party is Oscar Nunez. I was going to say Oscar. Oscar. He makes up chance. Like I remember one of the gifts was like a really lusciously thick, fake ponytail that you ended up paying. I took that home. Yeah, and Oscar like started chants like, ponytail, pony. I mean, they're not really creative chance, but you'd be surprised how much they catch on. I remember one year Lee brought a small hand axe. That thing was
其实我想把它办回来。我停办了几年，因为，你知道，生活、孩子，还有，你知道诸如此类的事。对。但我每年都会举办洋基换宝派对。哦，没错，你是办过。那是个盛大的派对，每个人都会来，而且气氛超级热烈。对。我最喜欢在洋基换宝派对上见到的人是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我正想说奥斯卡。奥斯卡。他会带头喊口号。就像我记得其中一个礼物是一个非常丰厚浓密假马尾，你最后拍下来了。我把它带回家了。对，然后奥斯卡就开始带头喊口号，比如，马尾，马尾。我的意思是，这些口号其实并不怎么有创意，但你会惊讶它们居然这么受欢迎。我记得有一年李带了一把小型手斧。那东西可是
the hot trade. Yes. I want to put it out there. Guys, if you're going to a Yankee swap, consider bringing a small axe. Didn't the next year Lee brought a brand new water hose? A garden hose. A garden hose. That was also a hot item. Really popular. Just like practical household items that maybe you need, but you haven't been buying yourself? Well, the next Yankee swap party I have, I'm actually going to include the kids because those were adult only.
大热门。对。我想公开提出来。伙计们，如果你要去参加洋基换宝，考虑带一把小斧头。难道不是第二年李带了一条全新的水管吗？一根花园水管。一根花园水管。这也是一件热门商品。非常受欢迎。就像实用家居用品，也许你需要，但你一直没给自己买？嗯，我的下一个洋基换宝派对，我打算把孩子们也加进来，因为以前那些只限成年人参加。
Oh, yeah. And I want to do a family Yankee swap. Okay. Like an invite. The kids are such at the age where they're really getting into it. We went to one last year. But I want you to know, Jennifer, for all the people that used to come. So at the end of the night, there would be these crap gifts that people would not want.
哦，对。我想办一个家庭洋基换宝。好吧。就像发出邀请。孩子们现在这个年纪真的很喜欢这个。我们去年去过一个。但我想让你知道，珍妮娜，为了所有曾经来过的人。所以在派对结束时，会剩下一些大家都不想要的垃圾礼物。
and a friend of mine would, unbeknownst to me, hide them around my house. I remember this. And I would find them months later, like, because he really hid them. Yeah. Like, up, like, sort of on a top shelf by, like, the spare batteries would be like a weird porcelain clown. Yeah. You know? And Zach Woods brought this gift, and he said, Angela, I am the failure of Yankee Swap.
然后我一个朋友，在我不知情的情况下，把它们藏在我家各处。我还记得这事。几个月后我还会找到它们，因为他是真的很会藏。对。比如，藏在顶层架子上，比如备用电池旁边，会有一个奇怪的瓷小丑。对。你知道吗？扎克斯·伍兹带了这份礼物，他说，安吉拉，我是洋基换宝的失败者。
because he brought a Egyptian sarcastic... The King Tutte thing. It was a King Tut miniature sarcophagus. Yeah. That opened up and you could put things inside it. I fought for that. I thought it was really great. I loved that.
因为他带了一个埃及讽刺画……图坦卡蒙法老的东西。那是一个图坦卡蒙微型石棺。对。可以打开，你还能把东西放进去。我为了这个据理力争。我觉得这真的很棒。我很喜欢那个。
Well, it got traded a bunch and he was like, I don't think anyone likes it. I was like, Zach, you're wrong. I know I'm talking a lot about my Yankee swap party guys, but I was really inspired. Well, this is a side note about Zach Woods. You guys, he played Gabe in later seasons, and he became a good friend of ours. When my son was born, he did the same thing. He gave me a gift, and he said, I'm so sorry, I'm not good at buying gifts for children. I don't have kids yet.
嗯，它被换了好几次，他说，我觉得没人喜欢它。我说，扎克，你错了。我知道我一直在喋喋不休地讲我的洋基换宝派对，伙计们，但我真的很受启发。好吧，这是关于扎克斯·伍兹的一个题外话。伙计们，他在后来的几季中饰演加布，他成了我们的好朋友。我儿子出生时，他也做了同样的事。他送了我一份礼物，并说，真的很抱歉，我不擅长给小孩子买礼物。我还没有孩子。
I don't know. And it was this amazing astronaut costume that we still have today and used for dress-up. I think he's better at buying gifts than he was. I think you are, Zach, just FYI. All right, fast fact number two, this episode was directed by Charles McDougal. Oh, guys, do we have stories about Charles McDougal. I mean... First of all, he was British.
我不知道。那是一套神奇的宇航员服，我们直到今天还留着，用来玩角色扮演。我觉得他现在比以前更擅长买礼物了。我觉得你是的，扎克，仅供参考。好了，趣事二，这一集由查尔斯·麦克杜格尔导演。哦，伙计们，我们有太多关于查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的故事了。我是说……首先，他是英国人。
Yes. He's British. I'm bringing out the... Ccent, guys, I did my spin bike, and now I'm speaking like a Brit. He had directed before us the HBO series Rome, which, if anyone saw it, is about the Roman Empire and the killing of Julius Caesar. It is epic. It's also brutal. It's brutal.
对。他是英国人。我要拿出我的……口音了，伙计们，我刚骑完动感单车，现在我说话就像个英国人了。他在我们之前导演过HBO剧集《罗马》，如果有人看过的话，讲的是罗马帝国和刺杀尤利乌斯·恺世。太史诗了。而且很残酷。很残酷。
They shot in Malta. There was chariots and horses and people getting impaled. Yes. And so he went from that to our quiet little Dunder Mifflin office. A little Christmas party. A little Christmas party. And you guys, the directors that had directed us prior to him were Ken Quapas, who might be the quietest human on the planet. Correct.
他们在马耳他拍摄。有战车、有马匹，还有人被刺穿。对。所以他从那种场景转到了我们这个安静的小邓德米夫林办公室。一个小型圣诞派对。一个小型圣诞派对。而且伙计们，在他之前导演过我们的导演是肯·夸帕斯，他可能是地球上最安静的人了。没错。
He says, you know, when he wants to start a scene, he just says, uh, go ahead. And when he gives a note, he'll say, Jenna, um, you know what, no, just go ahead. Yeah. That's Ken Quapas. Yeah. You all heard Paul Feig. Paul Feig is like, hey, hey, gang, how's it going? Hey, we're going to have fun today.
他说，你知道，当他想开始一个场景时，他只会说，呃，开始吧。当他给出调整意见时，他会说，珍娜，嗯，你知道吗，不，直接开始吧。对。这就是肯·夸帕斯。对。你们都听过保罗·费格。保罗·费格就像是，嘿，嘿，各位，最近怎么样？嘿，我们今天要玩得开心。
okay action yeah Charles McDougall rolls in we're all sitting at our desks quietly about to start the first scene and he goes wait brace yourself brace yourself brace yourself he goes actors action yes we I thought Phyllis ped herself a little I I tinkled I mean I was terrified I jumped straight up he was like action I was like oh my gosh what's happening what's happening is Tom Cruise through the ceiling any minute? I'm telling you that first day, the first moment of every scene, we all looked like deer in headlights. We would flinch.
好吧，Action。没错。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔大摇大摆地走进来，我们都静静地坐在办公桌前，准备开始第一个场景，然后他说，等等，做好心理准备，做好心理准备，做好心理准备。他说，演员们，Action。是的，我们……我以为菲利斯吓得放了个小屁。我吓尿了。我是说我快吓死了。我直接跳了起来。他就像是，Action，我当时就想，哦天哪，发生什么了？发生什么了？汤姆·克鲁斯下一秒会从天花板掉下来吗？我告诉你们，第一天，每个场景的开始，我们看起来都像是在车灯前的鹿一样。我们会畏缩。
We would flinch and then we would go into a scene. But then you guys, we just grew to love this guy. Oh. He would say things like we'd be working on a scene and he'd be like, all right, you know, let's go again. Actors, nearly there. Yes. Nearly there.
我们会畏缩，然后进入场景。但随后，伙计们，我们渐渐爱上了这家伙。哦。他会说这样的话，我们在处理一个场景时，他会说，好吧，你知道，我们再来一次。演员们，差不多了。对。差不多了。
And then I... He one time said, he said, all right, everyone, that was good for. For cameras, actors, better this time? Yeah. Like, oh, okay. And then as we... We'll try to be better this time. As we got into the episode more and the party started, he would walk up to me to be like,
然后我……他有一次说，他说，好了，大家，拍镜头这样可以了。演员们，这次能更好吗？对。就像，哦，好吧。然后随着我们……我们会努力这次表现得更好。随着我们更多地进入这一集，派对开始，他会走向我，像是在说，
Angela, remember, you're really pissed. You're really pissed now. And he sort of, and I'm going to get into it. It's on a, it's on like four or five note cards. But he sort of highlighted the level of, I called it Angela's pissed offness. Yeah. And it had like, it was like building. to a crescendo. And so towards the end, he would just yell before a big take in the party. He'd be like,
安吉拉，记住，你真的很生气。你现在真的很生气。他有点，我要深入讲讲这个。这是写在大概四五张便签卡上的。但他有点强调了那个程度，我称之为“安吉拉的愤怒值”。对。它就像是……在逐渐达到高潮。所以在接近尾声时，在派对上的一个大镜头之前，他就会直接大喊。他会说，
all right, everyone happy, Angela Pist and action. Yes. It was amazing. It was amazing. I just think it's so interesting that he went from filming all these chariots to filming people in a circle. Yeah. Sitting in a circle. What was that like for him? On desk chairs. Yes. Okay. Fast fact number three. Vance, Vance Refrigeration. We meet Phyllis's boyfriend. Yes, her new boyfriend. He works across the hall.
好了，大家，开心点，安吉拉，生气，Action。是的。太棒了。这太棒了。我只是觉得很有趣，他从拍摄所有这些战车，变成了拍摄围成一圈的人。对。围成一圈坐着。对他来说那是什么样的体验？坐在办公椅上。是的。好吧，趣事三。万斯，万斯冷冻公司。我们遇到了菲利斯的男友。对，她的新男友。他在大厅对面工作。
He's played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. He went on to do 24 episodes of The Office, including our finale. So here's a little tidbit. Mike Scher, our writer, said that the way that Bob Vance always introduces himself as Bob Vance, Vance, Vance Refigeration, is based on a friend of his. Actor Hayes MacArthur, who he says, for years, would introduce. himself as Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. Hayes, MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois.
他由鲍比·雷·谢弗饰演。他后来出演了24集《办公室》，包括我们的结局。所以这里有个小花絮。迈克·谢尔，我们的编剧，说鲍勃·万斯自我介绍总是说“鲍勃·万斯，万斯冷冻公司”的方式，是基于他的一个朋友。演员海斯·麦克阿瑟，他说海斯多年来都会自我介绍说，自己是伊利诺伊州芝加哥的海斯·麦克阿瑟。海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。
You guys, you might know Hayes. He would later go on to star with Rashida Jones on Angie Tribeca, which was created by Steve and Nancy Carrell. Small world. Small world. But I feel comfortable sharing that story about Hayes because I know him as well. And Mike said it on the DVD commentary. So he shared that with us on set.
伙计们，你们可能认识海斯。他后来与拉什达·琼斯一起主演了由史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔创作的《爆笑女警》。世界真小。世界真小。但我很乐意分享那个关于海斯的故事，因为我也认识他。迈克在DVD评论音轨里说过。所以他在片场跟我们分享过这个。
But since he put it out there, I was like, well, Mike, you already said it. So I'm going to share it here. Yeah. Well, you know what? I think that some people do that. I mean, I know in my hometown, you know, I'm from a very small town in Texas. And there are people in my town that we, no one ever says just their first name. I don't know why, but my mom's really good friend, her first name is Sue and her last name is Dean.
但既然他已经公开了，我就想，好吧，迈克，你已经说过了。所以我在这里分享一下。对。好吧，你知道吗？我觉得有些人就是这样。我是说，我知道在我的家乡，你知道，我来自德克萨斯州的一个小镇。我镇上有些人，我们，从来没有人只叫他们的名。我不知道为什么，但我妈妈的一个好朋友，她名叫苏，姓丁。
But everyone in the town calls her Sue Dean. Oh, yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are you, Sue Dean? It'd be like, Jenna Fisher. How are you, Jennifer? I'm good, Jennifer. I mean, so there are some people whose names just, you just do that.
但镇上的每个人都叫她苏·丁。哦，对。嗨，苏·丁。你好吗，苏·丁？就像是，珍娜·费舍。你好吗，珍妮弗？我很好，珍妮弗。我的意思是，所以有些人的名字就是，你自然而然就会那样叫。
Yeah. Well, we had some fans right in and ask, why does he always? say, Bob Vance, Van's Refrigeration. It was inspired by one of Mike's friends. I love it. Many people, before we go to break, many people wrote in to tell us that Mindy's Hair is down. I've, I've maybe not received so many notes. In this episode? No, it's down. No, it's partially up. It's partially up. Oh, well, Jennifer Dennett said that Mindy's Hair is down. Jennifer Dennett, I'm going to send you a screen grab. I mean, maybe she means down because it's not in the French twist. It's not the French twist, but she has had a few half up, half down. She's had a few half up, half downs. But I would say there's more down than up. Jennifer, there's more down than up. That's what she said. Well, I hope she doesn't say that. We would hope there's more up than down. All right, let's go to break.
好吧，我们有一些粉丝写信来问，为什么他总是说，“鲍勃·万斯，万斯冷冻公司”？这是受到迈克的一个朋友的启发。我太喜欢了。很多人，在我们休息之前，很多人写信告诉我们，明迪的头发是散开的。我，我可能从来没收到过这么多便签。在这个场景里？不，是散开的。不，是半扎起来的。是半扎起来的。哦，好吧，珍妮弗·丹尼特说明迪的头发是散开的。珍妮弗·丹尼特，我要给你发个截图。我是说，也许她说散开是因为它不是法式盘发。不是法式盘发，但她有几次是半扎半放的。她有过几次半扎半放。但我可以说放下来的比扎起来的多。珍妮弗，放下来的比扎起来的多。她是这么说的。好吧，我希望她没这么说。我们希望扎起来的比放下来的多。好了，我们去休息一下。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here we are. It's the holidays. Holidays are a time of traditions. I think when you think of holiday tradition you're usually thinking about, oh, how do we decorate? How do we exchange gifts? But I wonder if we should add something a new tradition to the holidays, which is the tradition of self-care. Oh, I like that. Right? Yeah. Because it can be a hectic and chaotic time. Absolutely. And also it can be a lonely time, you know? Yes. And prioritizing the tradition of self-care at the holidays, I feel like we need to add that to the list. I really like that. Well, you know, you're probably having to deal with a lot of folks around the holidays, and therapy can be a way for you to learn positive coping skills, how to reset your boundaries
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。所以我们来了。这就是假期。假期是传统的时刻。我想当你想到假日传统时，你通常会想到，哦，我们怎么装饰？我们怎么交换礼物？但我想知道我们是否应该为假期添点新传统，也就是自我关怀的传统。哦，我喜欢这个。对吧？对。因为这段时间可能会忙碌而混乱。绝对的。而且这也可能是一段孤独的时光，你知道吗？是的。在假期里优先考虑自我关怀的传统，我觉得我们需要把它加到清单上。我真的很喜欢这个。好吧，你知道，在假期里你可能需要应对很多人，而疗愈可以成为你学习积极应对技巧的一种方式，如何重设你的边界
or just set your boundaries and empower yourself to be the best version of yourself. So consider trying BetterHelp online therapy in December as a way to close the year with clarity rather than chaos. This December, start a new tradition by taking care of you. Our listeners get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash Office Ladies. That's better, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right, so let's dive in here. We've got the cold open.
或者仅仅是设定你的边界，并赋予自己力量，成为最好的自己。所以在12月考虑尝试一下BetterHelp在线疗愈，以此来带着清晰而非混乱的心情结束这一年。今年12月，通过照顾好自己来开启一项新传统。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com/OfficeLadies可享九折优惠。网址是better，H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。好的，那我们现在深入正题。我们有开场喜剧桥段。
In the very first few seconds, Pam is stuffing the Christmas envelopes, the Christmas photo. Yeah. Right? She's doing the Christmas card, mass mailing. The Christmas card. I did this at 1-800 dentist. Oh, you did the 1-800 dentist company Christmas card mailing?
在最初的几秒钟里，帕姆在装圣诞信封，圣诞照片。对。对吧？她在弄圣诞卡，进行群发。圣诞卡。我在1-800-牙医公司做过这个。哦，你做过1-800-牙医公司的圣诞卡群发？
I did. I volunteered and you got to hop off the phone so you didn't have to talk to people about like their rotten teeth. Yeah. And I would go in the mail. room and they'd be playing Christmas music, and I'd have a cup of tea, and I would just stuff envelopes all day, and I was so happy. Oh, yeah. I did many, many mass mailings as an administrative assistant. I'd have to bind things, copy on both sides, collate, bind, and mail. I'm very happy
我做过。我自告奋勇，这样你就可以不用接电话，不用跟别人讨论他们烂掉的牙齿了。对。然后我会去收发室，那里会放着圣诞音乐，我端着一杯茶，一整天都在装信封，我当时太开心了。哦，对。作为行政助理，我做过很多次群发信件。我得装订文件、双面复印、整理、装订和邮寄。我非常乐意
doing those things. Okay, but the photo was our cast photo that we took our Christmas photo. It was not our Christmas photo. What? Oh, yeah. It was, I, listen, I maybe got a little too obsessed with it, but I thought I recognized it. I screenabbed it. Me too. It's our season one publicity photo from the pilot.
做这些事情。好吧，但那张照片是我们拍的圣诞照片，我们的演员照。那不是我们的圣诞照片。什么？哦，对。那是，我，听着，我可能对它有点太着迷了，但我以为我认出它来了。我截屏了。我也是。那是我们在第一季试播集时的宣传照。
You're right. Because I'm sitting in the front. Oh, my gosh. And we're not wearing any Christmas stuff. Oh, Jenna. Good catch. I totally just thought it was our Christmas picture. Well, we had a fan question from Pizuki.
你说的对。因为我坐在最前面。哦，天哪。而且我们没有穿任何圣诞节的衣服。哦，珍娜。观察真仔细。我完全以为那是我们的圣诞照片。好吧，我们有一个来自Pizuki的粉丝提问。
Did anyone keep it? a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning. Well, I don't have a copy of the card, but I have a copy of that picture hanging in my office. And I examined it against the card that Pam is putting into the envelopes. Well, remember in the pilot, who's my detective? Henriette. Thank you so much, CSI office ladies. Henriette is in that photo. Henriette is in the photo on my wall because she was in the pilot. it. They photoshopped Kate's head onto Henriette's body for the picture I'm stuffing into the envelope in this episode. I really want that card. Dang it. Yeah, because I can see it's Henriette's
有人保留了帕姆在开头塞进信封的那张假日卡片的副本吗？好吧，我没有卡片的副本，但我办公室里挂着那张照片的副本。我拿它和帕姆塞进信封的卡片做了对比。好吧，还记得在试播集里，我的侦探是谁吗？亨丽埃特。非常感谢，CSI办公室女郎。亨丽埃特就在那张照片里。亨丽埃特就在我墙上的照片里，因为她演了试播集。他们把凯特的头P到了亨丽埃特的身体上，成了我在这一集里塞进信封的照片。我真的很想要那张卡片。该死。对，因为我能看出那是亨丽埃特的
hand on her hip in the sweater that's hanging in my office, but Kate's face. Way to go, Jenna. So far we've covered one second of the episode. That happens in the first one to three seconds. The next thing that happens is that Michael and Dwight enter with the tree. And it's, really way too big. That's way too big. It goes through the ceiling. I feel like this is a little nod to Christmas vacation. Yes.
手叉在腰上，穿着挂在我办公室里的毛衣，但脸是凯特的。真有你的，珍娜。到目前为止，我们才讲了一秒钟的剧情。那是发生在头一到三秒钟的事。接下来发生的事情是迈克尔和德怀特搬着圣诞树进来了。这树，真的太大了。太大了。它都穿过天花板了。我觉得这有点在向《疯狂假期》致敬。对。
You know, with Chevy Chase and that enormous tree. Yes. Well, do you remember when we were on set about three or four times when they pushed it up, the ceiling towel actually fell down and would fall on Steve's head? And then they'd have to brush them off with a little brush and fix his hair. There was little pieces of white sort of like particle-looking stuff all over the ground because the ceiling kept busting apart. Yeah. I loved that Kevin cuts the top of the Christmas tree with a paper trimmer.
你知道的，切维·切斯和那棵巨大的树。对。好吧，你还记得当我们在片场时，他们把树往上推了大概三四次，天花板的瓷砖真的掉下来了，砸到了史蒂夫的头上吗？然后他们得用一个小刷子帮他刷掉碎屑并整理头发。地上到处都是白色的小块，看起来像颗粒状的东西，因为天花板一直在碎裂。对。我太喜欢凯文用切纸机切掉圣诞树顶部的桥段了。
Yeah. I just thought that was such a nice touch. Well, it makes sense. It's what we'd have. It's what we would have. Yeah. Okay, I did kind of an Angela thing. What's that?
对。我只是觉得这真是一个绝妙的细节。好吧，这很合理。这就是我们会做的事。这就是我们会做的事。对。好吧，我做了一件很安吉拉的事。什么事？
Did you drink rosé during the day? I did not. But I did. I wrote down everybody's Christmas outfits. I love this. So did I. You did? Okay, let's do it.
你白天喝桃红葡萄酒了吗？我没有。但我做了。我写下了每个人的圣诞服装。我太喜欢这个了。我也是。你做了？好吧，那我们来盘点一下。
Okay. All right. I noticed that Michael has a Christmas tie. Yes, he does. It has a Santa on it and some snow. man, go. Christmas, tie, Kevin. Yes, snowman, wintery scene. All right, you and I both only have a Christmas pin and Christmas earrings. You have Christmas ornament earrings. I have Christmas stocking earrings, and we both have a version of a Santa Claus pin. Interesting. We're dressed
好。好吧。我注意到迈克尔系着一条圣诞领带。是的，他系了。上面有圣诞老人和一些雪人，走起。圣诞，领带，凯文。对，雪人，冬日场景。好吧，你和我身上都只有圣诞胸针和圣诞耳环。你戴的是圣诞饰品耳环。我戴的是圣诞袜耳环，而且我们俩都戴着某种圣诞老人胸针。有趣。我们穿得
kind of similar. Very similarly. What's that about? I don't know, but Phyllis has a full Christmas blouse and vest. I love her Christmas vest. My sister's a school teacher, and she does that. Like, I Christmas time, she wears all these Christmas sweaters and vests. You know I love this stuff. I've got all of it. My mom back in St. Louis, Missouri, every year, she goes to the local art fairs and craft fairs and she sends me Christmas hoodies, Christmas vests, Christmas pajamas, Christmas everything. I mean, those earrings could have been yours because you've come to my house at Christmas and you always have on Christmas jewelry. I'll tell you right now, I would never show up at a Christmas party and only Christmas earrings and Christmas tin. I mean, that is, I know. I know. I know. I
挺像的。非常相似。这是怎么回事？我不知道，但菲利斯穿了一件完整的圣诞衬衫和马甲。我喜欢她的圣诞马甲。我妹妹是个学校老师，她就会这样。就像，圣诞节的时候，她会穿所有这些圣诞毛衣和马甲。你知道我有多喜欢这些东西。我全都有。我在圣路易斯的妈妈，每年她都会去当地的艺术展和工艺品展，然后给我寄圣诞连帽衫、圣诞马甲、圣诞睡衣，圣诞的一切。我是说，那些耳环本来可以是你的，因为你圣诞节来我家时，总是戴着圣诞首饰。我现在就告诉你，我绝不会只戴着圣诞耳环和圣诞胸针就去参加圣诞派对。我是说，那是，我知道。我知道。我知道。我
I go all out. You go all out. Oh, Oscar has a Christmas tie. Oscar has a Christmas tie. Stanley has a red tie. So I guess that's his attempt. Very Stanley. That's as far as he would go.
我会全力以赴。你确实全力以赴。哦，奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。斯坦利系了一条红领带。所以我想那是他的尝试。非常斯坦利。这就是他的极限了。
I'm actually surprised he went that far. No. For Stanley. I know. Also, Meredith has a crazy Christmas sweater. Mm-hmm. Yeah. See, if it were me, I would be Meredith or Phyllis showing up to your party.
我其实很惊讶他居然做到了这一步。没有。对于斯坦利来说。我知道。还有，梅雷迪思穿着一件疯狂的圣诞毛衣。嗯哼。对。你看，如果是我，我就会像梅雷迪思或菲利斯那样去参加你的派对。
Full outfit. I know. I've seen how you come to my party. I love it. All right. Okay. So in this scene. that's coming up, Jim reveals that he got Pam and Secret Santa.
全套行头。我知道。我见过你是怎么来我的派对的。我太喜欢了。好吧。好的。所以在接下来这个场景中，
He does. Can I, listen, Jim fans, you're probably not going to like me for saying this, but at two minutes, two seconds, in his talking head, he says, he wants, you know, he got Pam for Secret Santa, and he said because Pam wants a teapot so she can make tea at her desk. Yeah. And I wrote WTF, who makes tea at their desk? She would go in the kitchen. What is she going to do?
吉姆透露他抽到了帕姆作为神秘老人礼物交换的对象。他确实抽到了。听着，吉姆的粉丝们，你们可能不会喜欢我这么说，但在2分02秒时，在他的独白中，他说，他想，你知道，他抽到了帕姆作为神秘老人，他说因为帕姆想要一个茶壶，这样她就能在办公桌上泡茶了。对。我写了WTF（什么鬼），谁会在办公桌上泡茶？她会去厨房的。她要干嘛？
go to the kitchen, put the hot water in the teapot, carry it back to her desk, pour herself a cup of tea at her desk. Exactly. She's going to carry that teapot from the kitchen. What part of this is confusing you? I think is ridiculous. Okay. Here's her other option.
去厨房，把热水倒进茶壶里，把它拿回办公桌，在办公桌上给自己倒一杯茶。没错。她要把那个茶壶从厨房端过来。这有什么让人费解的？我觉得这太荒谬了。好吧。这是她的另一个选择。
Okay. Yeah. She goes into the kitchen. Yeah. Oh, I see the breakdown. I see how your brain is tracking it and why it doesn't make sense. And also because I know you and you just put the tea bag right into the cup, which is a totally acceptable way to make a... I know some people let it seep.
好吧。对。她去厨房。哦，我明白了整个逻辑链。我明白你的大脑是怎么想的，以及为什么这说不通。而且因为我了解你，你直接把茶包放进杯子里，这绝对是一种可以接受的……我知道有些人会让它浸泡。
Steep. Steep. Steep. Steep. With a tea. Let it seep on in there. You leave it in your pot. That's right. I said that the scene could be called something else. What could it be called? Instead of what's inside the teapot, it could be called Jim's got it bad. Oh. Because he saved two sauce packets from a few years ago. Yeah. That's someone who... has got it really bad. Okay. I, yeah, I feel like that could have been written a little differently, where Jim could have said a couple of years ago,
浸泡。浸泡。浸泡。用茶。让它在里面浸泡。你把它留在壶里。没错。我说这个场景可以叫别的名字。叫什么名字？除了“茶壶里装的是什么”，它还可以叫“吉姆陷得很深”。哦。因为他把两年前的两包酱料包留着。对。那是那种……陷得很深的人。好吧，我，是的，我觉得这段可以写得稍微有点不同，吉姆可以说几年前，
Pam did this thing with the hot sauce, and therefore I am putting a packet of hot sauce in there. The fact that he saved the two packets of hot sauce. For years. For years. He loves you. He loves you. He definitely does.
帕姆用辣酱做了这件事，因此我在里面放了一包辣酱。他居然把那两包辣酱留了几年。几年。他爱你。他爱你。他绝对爱你。
All right, well, I do have a lot to say about the teapot. So first of all, Phil Shea offered me a variety of teapots. before we started shooting in many colors. And I picked the teal. I love it. Yeah, I don't know. A little pop a color. The writers also said that picking what this gift would be,
好吧，关于这个茶壶，我确实有很多话要说。首先，在我们开始拍摄之前，菲尔·谢伊给我提供了各种颜色的茶壶。有很多种颜色。我选了青色。我很喜欢。对，我不知道。一点流行色。编剧们还说，挑选这个礼物会是什么，
the fact that it would be a teapot, provided a major challenge because they needed a gift that could hide other gifts that was really personal and that would be very stressful when Dwight takes it away from Pam. It could only cost $20, and it had to be something that Dwight really, wanted. And they said it was not easy. They spent a very long time because they knew plot wise what had to happen that Jim gives Pam a gift filled with secret treasures that Dwight also
是一个茶壶这一事实，带来了巨大的挑战，因为他们需要一份能够隐藏其他礼物的礼物，它必须非常个性化，而且当德怀特把它从帕姆手里拿走时，会让人感到非常紧张。它只能花20美元，而且必须是德怀特真正想要的东西。他们说这可不容易。他们花了很长时间，因为他们在剧情上知道必须发生什么，那就是吉姆给帕姆一个装满秘密宝藏的礼物，德怀特也
wants to have that costs under $20. It took them a very long time to come up with teapot. For that reason alone, okay, fine, Pam can make her tea at the counter. She can steep some tea at her desk. Because when Dwight puts it in his nose, I know that's later, but it's so perfect. It is. It's I mean, they nailed it, right? They nailed it. And now this teapot is famous. I mean, all the time, people are using this teapot idea to propose to their loved ones. I see it all the time.
想要拥有，而且价格在20美元以下。他们花了很长的时间才想出茶壶。仅凭这一点，好吧，行，帕姆可以在柜台泡茶。她可以在办公桌旁泡茶。因为当德怀特把它塞进鼻子时，我知道那是后面发生的，但它是如此完美。确实是。我是说，他们太棒了，对吧？他们太棒了。现在这个茶壶出名了。我是说，人们一直在用这个茶壶的想法向他们的爱人求婚。我经常看到。
And my Instagram, people are tagging me. It's always charming to me. It's always so sweet. It is very thoughtful. So we mentioned the things that he's putting into the teapot. Here's a fan question. Taylor Rilling said, what is the significance of the pencil that Jim puts in the teapot? Yeah, he said, the story is too long.
还有我的Instagram，人们在标记我。这对我来说总是很迷人。总是那么甜蜜。非常体贴。所以我们提到了他塞进茶壶里的东西。这是一个粉丝提问。泰勒·里林说，吉姆放进茶壶里的铅笔有什么意义？是的，他说，这个故事太长了。
So we have a deleted scene, and I remember shooting it. What Pam says when she picks up the pencil is she says, oh my gosh, this is the pencil I threw at you during minigolf. What? When did Jim and Pam go play mini golf? Maybe the whole office went and played mini golf. That seems like something Michael Scott would be like, we're going to play minigolf and we're going to raise money for my neighbors, like, whatever.
所以我们有一个被删减的镜头，我记得拍过。帕姆拿起铅笔时说的话是，哦天哪，这就是我在迷你高尔夫时扔向你的那支铅笔。什么？吉姆和帕姆什么时候去打迷你高尔夫了？也许整个办公室都去打迷你高尔夫了。这听起来像是迈克尔·斯科特会做的事，比如，我们要去打迷你高尔夫，我们要为我的邻居筹款，诸如此类的。
That's all I can think of is that there was some office outing where they went and played mini golf and I guess Pam got all feisty and threw a pencil at him and he saved it. So that's where the pencil is. And then, of course, he puts a card in the box and he says, because Christmas time is the time to tell people how you feel. Oh, yeah. That's so loaded. I have PPC next. Let's hit some PPC, the party planning committee. You know, Mike Scher also wrote the PPC.
我能想到的就是有一次办公室集体出游，他们去打迷你高尔夫，我猜帕姆变得很争强好胜，向他扔了一支铅笔，而他把它保存了下来。所以铅笔就是这么来的。然后，当然，他在盒子里放了一张卡片，他说，因为圣诞节是向人们表达你内心的时刻。哦，是的。太意味深长了。接下来我有PPC。让我们来看看PPC，派对策划委员会。你知道，迈克·舒尔也写了关于PPC的内容。
in the Alliance. I think he likes the PPC. Oh, he definitely likes the PPC and their weird sort of power struggle. He loves it. Well, in this scene, we find out that Ryan has been drafted into the PPC. I can't believe that. I remember that. I can't believe that Angela Martin would recruit him, except that maybe she needed help, like, someone setting up things and moving things. Well, the Christmas party is a big one. It's a big one. Yeah. Yeah. But also, I noticed that Meredith is in there. Yeah. No, it's all hands on deck.
在《同盟》中。我想他喜欢PPC。哦，他绝对喜欢PPC以及他们诡异的那种权力斗争。他很喜欢。好吧，在这个镜头中，我们发现瑞安被征召加入了PPC。我简直不敢相信。我记得那件事。我简直不敢相信安吉拉·马丁会招募他，除非她可能需要帮助，比如有人来布置场地和搬运东西。嗯，圣诞派对是个大派对。是个大派对。是的。是的。不过我也注意到梅雷迪思也在里面。是的。不，这是全员出动。
She probably has a bigger crew than just her core crew. Well, that's when Michael enters in his Santa beard. He throws down some cash because he wants a bigger, better party, and he reveals he has a digital camera and he will be taking photos.
她可能有一个比核心团队更大的团队。嗯，就在这时，迈克尔戴着圣诞老人胡子登场了。他扔下一些现金，因为他想要一个更大更好的派对，并且他透露他有一台数码相机，他会拍照。
Yeah, and he's going to put him in the newsletter. Most embarrassing one wins. Yes. I want you guys to know when Steve came behind Phyllis and I, and he was like, I want people making out, and he shoved her heads together
是的，他会把它放进时事通讯里。最尴尬的获胜。是的。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫走到菲利斯和我身后时，他就像是，我想要人们亲热，然后他把我们的头推到一起
and was like, la la, la. That was an improv. That was improv. Yeah. Phyllis and I didn't know that was coming. He just did it in the moment. I was really proud that neither of us started laughing. I'm proud.
然后说，啦啦，啦。那是即兴发挥。那是即兴发挥。是的。菲利斯和我事先都不知道。他只是当场做出来的。我真的很骄傲，我们两个谁都没有笑出来。我很骄傲。
I was so proud of myself because there were a few times in that scene I almost broke and I was really fighting it. Oh, it's also in this scene, Angela, that it's revealed that Phyllis was in charge of getting the lights for the Christmas tree. And she said she got the little ones. Yeah. And you have a reaction to that? Well, that's not going to go over well later. That is not going to go over. So like I said, I listened to the DVD commentary of this. And Mike was really good on the commentary at breaking down some of his goals for the episode. And his goal for the episode was that Angela would get more and more and more stressed out every scene that we see her. And I think you can track that. Like as I was watching it again, I can totally see that. I have five note cards called Angela's Pissed Offness. Yes. That I'm going to start with time code soon before.
我为自己感到骄傲，因为在那个场景中有好几次我差点笑场，我一直在努力克制。哦，也是在这个场景里，安吉拉，大家发现菲利斯负责采购圣诞树的灯饰。她说她买的是小灯。是的。你对此有什么反应？嗯，这事以后可不好收场。那可真不好收场。所以就像我说的，我听了这集的DVD评论音轨。迈克在评论中非常擅长剖析他在这一集中的一些目标。他对这一集的目标是，在每一个镜头中，安吉拉都会变得越来越焦虑。我想你能看出来。就像我再次观看时，我完全能看出来。我有五张记事卡，上面写着“安吉拉气炸了”。是的。我很快就会在之前加入时间码。
we get into all that, I do have to point out because I was texting with Kim Ferry, who did my hair for nine years on the office last night, this is the Angela hair braid. That is my actual hair that she had me bend over and braid. And of course, my character would want to wear it to the Christmas party. I feel like this was her special braid. For special occasions. For special occasions. And while we're talking PPC, guys, I have to say, Pam, Pam would probably. probably irk me too on this committee. What? I mean, at four minutes, 25 seconds, Angela is trying to put a tablecloth on this table. Pam is just staring at her doing nothing, not trying to grab for the tablecloth, help her spread it out, anything. And Angela just looks at her and it's just like, will you help me? When I saw that scene, I found it so satisfying. It's her little bit of defiance against your just crazy controlling. Yes, yes, just you're everything that's coming at her. And, you know, I told you, I go back and I read my journals, and I had written, and I also
在我们讨论所有这些之前，我必须指出来，因为我昨晚和金·费里发过短信，她在《办公室》里连续九年为我做发型，这就是安吉拉的辫子发型。那是我的真发，她让我弯下腰编出来的。当然，我的角色会想在圣诞派对上戴着它。我觉得这是她专属的辫子。为了特殊场合。为了特殊场合。在我们谈论PPC的时候，伙计们，我必须说，帕姆，帕姆可能。在这个委员会里也可能会惹恼我。什么？我是说，在4分25秒时，安吉拉正试图在这张桌子上铺桌布。帕姆就只是盯着她什么也不做，不试着去拿桌布，帮她把它铺开，什么都不做。安吉拉只是看着她，就像是，你能帮我一下吗？当我看到那个场景时，我觉得太令人爽快了。这是她对你那种疯狂控制欲的一点反抗。是的，是的，就是你向她袭来的所有一切。而且，你知道的，我告诉过你，我回去翻看了我的日记，我写过，而且我也
have these old blogs, and I had written in one of my old blogs that filming the scene where I don't help you put the tablecloth on was one of my favorites of the whole episode. It's such like passive aggressive defiance. I loved it. I loved it. Well, Jenna, I went and found my MySpace blogs. So they're not online anymore. I don't know why. But I, so, but I guess I had printed them out at some point. Smart. So now I'm going to start going to them for each episode. And I did for this one, but I'll save it for a bit. Because it happens later in the episode. Okay, great. Fan question from small actor in a peacoat. Who kept the camera with all of the pictures that Michael took? NBC. Yeah, they were property of NBC, and they had them up on their website for a while. But guess what? You can still find them.
有这些旧博客，我在其中一个旧博客里写过，拍摄我不帮你铺桌布那个场景是整集中我最喜欢的场景之一。这真是一种被动攻击式的反抗。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，我去找到了我的MySpace博客。所以它们现在不在网上了。我不知道为什么。但是，所以，我猜我当时在某个时候把它们打印出来了。真聪明。所以现在我要开始在每一集里查看它们了。这一集我也这么做了，不过我先保留一会儿。因为这发生在这一集的后面。好的，太棒了。来自“穿呢子大衣的小演员”的粉丝提问。谁保管了装着迈克尔拍的所有照片的相机？NBC。是的，那是NBC的财产，他们在网站上挂了一段时间。但是你猜怎么着？你还是能找到它们。
And Jenna and I were texting last night. We both found him over at office tally.com. Yeah. So you can see all those pictures that he was really taking pictures. Yeah, and they're really, like, not centered, and, like, people's heads are cut off. It's as if he just went around clicking away, but there's some real gyms in there. I know. Six minutes, 54 seconds.
珍娜和我昨晚发短信了。我们都在office tally.com找到了。是的。所以你可以看到所有那些照片，他真的是在拍照。是的，而且它们真的，比如，没有对准中心，而且，比如人的头被切掉了。就好像他只是到处乱按快门，但里面有一些真正的宝贝。我知道。6分54秒。
Michael really, really shows what he thinks about Christmas, which is a gift should say, I love you, this many dollars worth. Yeah. Oh, this is not going to go well. Well, speaking of gifts, we have a scene where Toby reveals what he got Angela in Secret Santa. And it is the Jazz Baby poster. Yeah. I have that poster, guys. You have it?
迈克尔真正地展现了他对圣诞节的看法，那就是一份礼物应该表达，我爱你有这么多钱的价值。是的。哦，这下可不好办了。嗯，说到礼物，我们有一个场景，托比透露了他在秘密圣诞老人活动中送给安吉拉的礼物。那是爵士宝贝海报。是的。我有那张海报，伙计们。你有？
That was one of my questions from Chris Cordova. wants to know, did you keep the baby poster? Well, there was about 20 of them. They made a bunch. One hung by my desk for years. Yes. Yeah. So we got to see it every day. And I have one. It's rolled up in a little poster thingy. Now, do you know the story behind that picture? Because I traded some text messages with Phil Shea. Mm-hmm. So Phil Shea had to make that poster. He did not buy that poster. He put out a casting call for babies. And two babies were cast, baby actors. He said it was really hard to find tiny jazz instruments. He said that was really difficult. In fact, he said, you know, Amazon didn't exist back then. You know, you couldn't just Google baby jazz
那是克里斯·科尔多瓦的提问之一。想知道，你留下了那个宝贝海报吗？嗯，大约有20张。他们制作了一堆。一张挂在我的办公桌旁好几年。是的。是的。所以我们每天都能看到它。我有一张。它被卷成一个小海报筒里。那么，你知道那张照片背后的故事吗？因为我和菲尔·谢伊发了一些短信。嗯哼。所以菲尔·谢伊不得不制作那张海报。他没有买那张海报。他发布了一个婴儿选角通告。两个婴儿被选中了，是婴儿演员。他说找微型爵士乐器真的很难。他说那真的很难。事实上，他说，你知道，那时候亚马逊还不存在。你知道，你不能只是在谷歌上搜索婴儿爵士
instrument. And they couldn't be fake looking, like they couldn't be like blue and pink. So he did eventually find them at a place called Hollywood costumes. He was particularly proud of the tiny sunglasses that he found. This poster ends up coming back in conflict resolution. Like you said, it stayed up there, but then it comes back again. It comes back again. I would like to know the two babies that were in the poster. Oh, guys.
乐器。而且它们不能看起来是假的，比如它们不能是蓝色和粉色的。所以他最终在一家名为“好莱坞服装”的地方找到了它们。他对找到的微型太阳镜尤为自豪。这张海报最终在《冲突解决》中再次出现。就像你说的，它一直挂在那里，但后来又出现了。它又出现了。我想知道海报里的两个婴儿是谁。哦，伙计们。
Where are they today? If you are a baby from the baby jazz poster, will you please write to us at office ladies at earwolf.com? One thing about that baby jazz poster, I remember Mike Scher telling me that they thought it was really funny that Angela would really enjoy babies dressed as adults. Okay, where are we? Well, we're talking about the gifts,
他们今天在哪里？如果你是婴儿爵士海报里的那个婴儿，请给我们写信，邮箱是office ladies@earwolf.com。关于那张婴儿爵士海报，我记得迈克·舒尔告诉我，他们觉得安吉拉会非常喜欢打扮成成年人的婴儿，这非常搞笑。好了，我们到哪儿了？嗯，我们在讨论礼物，
and Mike Scher actually said that the gifts were incredibly hard to manage because they start off as Secret Santa, so everybody had a person that they bought a specific gift for, and then you had to track the gifts as they went around in the Yankee swap. He actually, in the script of this episode, there is a whole page where he lists the gifts. Who bought, who, what? And he did this for Veda, our script supervisor.
迈克·舒尔实际上说过，这些礼物极其难以管理，因为它们一开始是秘密圣诞老人活动，所以每个人都有一个他们专门为其购买礼物的人，然后你必须在洋基交换中追踪这些礼物。实际上，在本集的剧本中，有一整页他列出了礼物。谁买了谁的，什么？他是为我们的剧本主管维达做的这件事。
We haven't really talked about her, but Veda's job is to sit and watch every take that is filmed and make notes about everything that happens continuity-wise. So, I mean, like, really specific. So, like, if in a scene you take a drink of your tea on a certain line and then scratch your nose on another one, Veda writes it down. so that you do it the same every time for editing purposes. Yeah, Veda would come up to us and say,
我们没有怎么谈论过她，但维达的工作是坐着观看拍摄的每一个镜头，并对连续性方面发生的一切做笔记。所以，我是说，真的非常具体。所以，如果在某个场景中你在某句台词时喝了茶，然后在另一句台词时挠了鼻子，维达都会记下来。这样出于剪辑的目的，你每一次都会做得一模一样。是的，维达会走到我们面前说，
Angela, you were holding that pen in your left hand in the first take, and in the second take you picked it up and held it in your right hand. So that's not going to match. So you need to pick which hand you're going to hold that pin in and do it in every take the same way. Yeah, because otherwise, when you edit it together, the pen is magically bouncing from hand to hand. So Mike was really worried about Veda in this episode,
安吉拉，你在第一个镜头里是用左手拿那支笔的，而在第二个镜头里你把它拿起来换到了右手。所以这不连贯。所以你需要选定你打算用哪只手拿那支笔，并且在每一个镜头里都以同样的方式去做。是的，因为否则，当你把它剪辑到一起时，那支笔就会神奇地在两只手中跳来跳去。所以迈克在这集中非常担心维达，
and so he made this list just for Veda. And I have it from the script. Oh, fantastic. Okay, so this is what everyone was intended to give. And we got a lot of fan questions about this. Like a lot of people wrote in and said, you know, eventually Michael's going to get the paintball lessons from Dwight. But they're like, who did Dwight intend that to go to? So I have all the answers right here.
于是他专门为维达制作了这份清单。我是从剧本里拿到的。哦，太棒了。好的，这就是每个人原本打算送的礼物。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。比如很多人写信来说，你知道的，迈克尔最终会从德怀特那里得到彩弹射击课程。但他们说，德怀特原本打算把这个送给谁？所以我这里有所有的答案。
Are you ready? Yeah. Okay. Dwight got Phyllis, the paintball lessons and the pellets. That was his gift to Phyllis. Phyllis made Michael an oven mitt. Michael got Ryan an iPod. Ryan got Toby a book of short stories by George Saunders, who happens to be one of Mike Scher's favorite writers.
准备好了吗？是的。好的。德怀特送给菲利斯彩弹射击课程和彩弹。那是他送给菲利斯的礼物。菲利斯给迈克尔做了一个隔热手套。迈克尔给瑞安买了一个iPod。瑞安给托比买了一本乔治·桑德斯的短篇小说集，乔治·桑德斯正好是迈克·舒尔最喜欢的作家之一。
Toby got Angela the baby poster. Angela bought Stanley a picture frame. Stanley got Kelly a nameplate. Kelly got Oscar a shower radio. Oscar got Creed a shamrock keychain. Creed got Jim one of his own shirts. Jim got Pam the teapot, and this is something that got cut out. Pam made Meredith a drawing of the office.
托比给安吉拉买了婴儿海报。安吉拉给斯坦利买了一个相框。斯坦利给凯利买了一个名牌。凯利给奥斯卡买了一个淋浴收音机。奥斯卡给克里德买了一个三叶草钥匙扣。克里德给吉姆买了他自己的衬衫之一。吉姆给帕姆买了茶壶，这是一段被删减掉的内容。帕姆给梅雷迪思画了一幅办公室的画。
I read about that online. Yeah, and there was this big thing. It's in the deleted scenes. This is something I have to tell you. I got a DVD player for Christmas. What? My husband got me a DVD player. So I got the CDs.
我在网上读到过这个。是的，当时有一件大事。它在被删减的镜头里。这是我必须告诉你的事。我圣诞节收到了一台DVD播放机。什么？我丈夫给我买了一台DVD播放机。所以我得到了CD。
He bought me the CD set, and I got a DVD player. And last night, I got to watch all the deleted scenes. Oh, Angela, you must be so happy. I was so happy, and there's so many. Oh, yeah. There's so many. For the Christmas episode, you guys, there are so many great deleted scenes. I don't want to get us off topic here, but they're in the deleted scenes.
他给我买了一套CD，我还得到了一台DVD播放机。昨晚，我看了所有被删减的镜头。哦，安吉拉，你一定太高兴了。我太高兴了，而且有那么多。哦，是的。有那么多。对于圣诞节那一集，你们知道，有那么多精彩的被删减镜头。我不想把我们的话题扯远，但它们就在被删减的镜头里。
Meredith opens up her painting. That is from Pam, and it's a drawing of the office. Well, there's a big backstory here. Again, with Phil, I don't do Pam's drawings. People ask me that all the time. I'm not an artist. I mean, we've talked about this. have we, that I do cartoons. I do cartooning. She's very good at cartooning, and I have a few that you've
梅雷迪思打开了她的画。那是来自帕姆的，这是一幅办公室的画。嗯，这里有一个很大的背景故事。还是关于菲尔的，我可不画帕姆的画。人们总是问我这个。我不是艺术家。我是说，我们讨论过这个，我们讨论过吗，我画漫画。我画漫画。她在画漫画方面很擅长，我保留了你画的一些
drawn that I've saved. I think you're fantastic. Well, I love my little expressive cartoons, but I needed Pam and wanted Pam to be a better artist than I am. So there is a young art student that does all of Pam's drawings. They went out to a bunch of people, like 12 different artists to turn in samples to be the artist behind Pam. And they picked. picked a young woman. Now, Jenna, I read, and you can tell me if this is true, I read that the first painting that they had for this episode to give to Meredith from Pam, that they had one of our set art people who was a man, do it. And when they looked at it, it looked too masculine. Yeah. And so then they went out to female artists to have a little bit of a softer touch.
我保存下来的画。我觉得你太棒了。嗯，我喜欢我那些充满表现力的漫画，但我需要并且希望帕姆在艺术上比我更有天赋。所以有一个年轻的艺术学生负责帕姆的所有画作。他们找了一群人，大约12位不同的艺术家来提交样本，以成为帕姆背后的艺术家。他们选中了。选中了一位年轻女性。现在，珍娜，我读到过，你可以告诉我这是不是真的，我读到过他们为这一集准备的送给梅雷迪思的第一幅来自帕姆的画，是由我们的一位男性布景美术人员画的。当他们看它时，它看起来太男性化了。是的。所以后来他们去找了女艺术家，想要一种稍微柔和一点的风格。
Yeah. And there were something like 12 different artists who all submitted their work. And I wish I knew her name. Unfortunately, I don't. But maybe I can find that out and reveal that in a future episode. And then so finally, two more gifts. Meredith got Dwight some shot glasses from Cancun and Kevin got himself a foot bath. Guys, around five minutes, 55 seconds, there is a scene where Michael is talking to Jim at Jim's desk. This is when he reveals that he got Ryan for Secret Santa.
是的，大约有12位不同的艺术家都提交了他们的作品。我真希望我知道她的名字。不幸的是，我不知道。但也许我可以查到并在以后的节目中揭晓。然后，最后还有两份礼物。梅雷迪思给德怀特买了一些来自坎昆的烈酒杯，凯文给自己买了一个足浴盆。伙计们，在大约5分55秒时，有一个场景是迈克尔在吉姆的办公桌旁跟吉姆说话。这就是他透露自己在秘密圣诞老人活动中抽中了瑞安的时候。
And I just want to say you see a ton of background action. Angela, you're walking from reception. Over Steve's shoulder, you see Toby and Mindy talking. Yeah. They are 100% not in character. Not in character at all. I saw that too. I was like, they're just talking about probably something in the writer's room or a story pitch.
我只想说，你能看到大量的背景动作。安吉拉，你正从前台走过来。在史蒂夫的肩膀上方，你能看到托比和敏迪在说话。是的。他们百分之百没有进入角色。一点也没有进入角色。我也看到了。我想，他们可能只是在讨论编剧室里的什么事情或者一个故事构思。
Or they're just having a conversation. Yeah. I mean, Paul is just being Paul. Yeah. If anyone's curious, the difference between Toby and Paul, go to five minutes, 55 seconds. And you can see Paul and Mindy having a conversation in the background. Yeah, exactly. Tree lighting!
或者他们只是在闲聊。是的。我是说，保罗只是在做保罗自己。是的。如果有人好奇托比和保罗的区别，去看看5分55秒。你能看到保罗和敏迪在背景里聊天。是的，没错。点亮圣诞树！
Okay. I have been waiting for this moment. The Christmas tree lighting, this starts the beginning of everyone happy Angela Pist. So this Christmas tree, the top of it has been hacked off by Kevin. It is covered in so much tinsel. Yeah. So much tinsel. It has a smattering of just blue and red ball ornaments. It's just not their best effort. And then it has the tiniest of tiny white lights, thanks to Phyllis. So Dwight makes a big deal of it. He like takes the outlet, like the plug. What do you call it?
好了。我一直在等待这一刻。圣诞树亮灯，这拉开了每个人都高兴而安吉拉气炸了的序幕。所以这棵圣诞树，它的树顶被凯文砍掉了。上面挂满了金属饰带。是的。挂了那么多的金属饰带。上面零星地点缀着一些蓝色和红色的球形饰品。这实在算不上他们最好的水平。然后它还有微乎其微的白色小灯，多亏了菲利斯。所以德怀特对此大惊小怪。他把电源插座拿过来，就像插头一样。你叫它什么？
The plug? The plug. He takes the plug from Stanley. He wants to plug it in. He's like just like Rockefeller Center. And everyone gathers around and it's like br-br-br-and-fil-And Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. And at six minutes, 38 seconds, you see my first pissed off face. Dang it, Phyllis.
插头？插头。他从斯坦利手里拿过插头。他想把它插上。他就像是在洛克菲勒中心一样。每个人都围过来，然后是兹拉兹拉兹拉——而菲利斯则说，我很抱歉。在6分38秒时，你看到了我第一个气炸了的表情。可恶，菲利斯。
It's also one of those moments where I feel like Angela's like, I knew it. knew it. I knew I couldn't trust her to do these lights. Why do I even have her do anything? Why do you have anyone do anything? Yeah. You can't let anyone do anything. These people are worthless. Exactly. You know, that Christmas tree light thing is based on a real thing from Mike Scher's life. I know. He said that when he and his wife got their first tree in New York, he bought a bunch of small lights for the tree, and he wrapped them around. And when he plugged it in, you couldn't really see I love that. I love when writers work those little moments from their real life into the show.
这也是那种让我觉得安吉拉心里在想“我早就知道了。我早就知道了。我早知道不能信任她来弄这些灯。为什么我还要让她做任何事？你为什么还要让任何人做任何事？”的时刻之一。是的。你不能让任何人做任何事。这些人毫无用处。没错。你知道，那个圣诞树亮灯的事情是基于迈克·舒尔生活中的真实事件。我知道。他说当他和妻子在纽约买第一棵树时，他为这棵树买了一堆小灯，把它们缠绕上去。当他把它插上电时，你根本看不出来我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢编剧们把生活中那些小瞬间融入剧集里的做法。
I thought, speaking about people who are acting like themselves instead of their characters, I thought Jim's talking head about Creed's gift is so John. It is John. That is John right there. Yeah. The delivery, the smile, all of it. And then, of course, Creed's talking head made me laugh so hard. Creed is very funny in this episode.
我想，说到那些表现得像他们自己而不是他们的角色的人，我觉得吉姆关于克里德礼物的独白太像约翰了。这就是约翰。那就是活生生的约翰。是的。说话的腔调，微笑，全都是。然后，当然，克里德的独白把我笑惨了。克里德这一集里非常搞笑。
I mean, everybody has some great moments. but Creed cracked me up a bunch in this episode. So now Secret Santa is starting. Yep. And everyone is gather around in some office chairs. And I want to say truly, I know we were joking about Charles McDougal, but the amount of energy and movement that he uses the camera to give this scene of people sitting in a circle, I mean, it is impressive from a directorial standpoint. I think, like, I don't want to be crazy, but I think, like, film student. should study this portion of the episode because I'm imagining myself trying to film a group of
我是说，每个人都有一些精彩的时刻。但克里德这一集把我逗笑了好多次。所以现在秘密圣诞老人活动开始了。是的。大家围坐在一些办公椅上。我想说的是，真的，我知道我们之前在拿查尔斯·麦克道格尔开玩笑，但他用摄像机来拍摄这个围坐成一圈互换礼物的场景时所运用的精力和运镜，我是说，从导演的角度来看，这令人印象深刻。我想，我不想显得太疯狂，但我觉得，电影专业的学生应该研究这一集的这一部分，因为我想象着自己去拍摄一群
people sitting in a circle doing a gift exchange and it would not look nearly this dynamic. It's really, really impressive directing. No, he's great. He is really great. Okay, so we're starting the Secret Santa and Pam opens Jim's teapot. She loves it, but Dwight moves things along so quickly that she doesn't have time to look inside or notice the card that's in the box. Yeah, Dwight wants no chitty chat between gifts.
人围成一圈交换礼物，绝对拍不出这么有动感的画面。这真的是非常非常棒的导演手法。不，他很棒。他真的很棒。好了，所以我们开始秘密圣诞老人活动，帕姆打开了吉姆的茶壶。她很喜欢，但德怀特把进度推进得太快了，以至于她没有时间看里面，也没有注意到盒子里那张卡片。是的，德怀特不希望在礼物之间有任何闲聊。
He's like, go, go, go, go. He's me coming in today. He is. He's like, save it for the mic. So he's moving things along. So it's Pam. And then the next one, we find out that Michael buys Ryan a video iPod that costs $400. You guys, this was not product placement. It was not so many people wanted to know. Yeah. We were not paid. It was just sort of a really cool topical gift at the time. Yeah. And they were trying to think of a gift that would sort of be a showstopper that Michael would think was very impressive, that every. one would want. So this was coincidence. We weren't paid to use it. So I read that, that
他就像是，快，快，快，快。他就像今天进组的我一样。他确实是。他就像是，留着去麦克风前说吧。所以他在推进进度。所以轮到帕姆了。然后下一个，我们发现迈克尔给瑞安买了一个价值400美元的视频iPod。伙计们，这不是产品植入。真的不是，有太多人想知道了。是的。我们没有拿钱。这只是当时一个非常酷的时髦礼物。是的。他们当时在想一件能压全场、让迈克尔觉得非常惊艳、每个人都想要的礼物。所以这纯属巧合。我们没有收钱使用它。所以我读到了那个，
well, here's something. A ton of people wanted to know who kept it at the end. Nobody. We weren't allowed to keep any of the stuff. It all goes into a giant warehouse and it gets labeled for the episode for props because if for some reason we have to go back and reshoot something, they take it off the shelf and they bring it back in. That's true. I don't know what happens after it's been in the warehouse for a while, but it just goes to prop house storage. I feel like it's still in a box labeled The Office Christmas Party. It probably is. There was a fan question from Beard Up, Beard Down.
嗯，这里有个情况。一大堆人想知道最后是谁留下了它。没有人。我们不允许保留任何东西。它们全都进入一个巨大的仓库，并贴上道具的标签，因为如果由于某种原因我们必须回去重拍某些东西，他们会把它从货架上拿下来，再拿回来。确实如此。我不知道它在仓库待了一段时间后会怎么样，但它只是去了道具仓库储存。我觉得它仍然在一个贴着“办公室圣诞派对”标签的箱子里。很可能是的。有一个来自“留胡子，刮胡子”的粉丝提问。
Was the iPod sponsored by Apple? It wasn't. We said it was not. It's just a total coincidence. But there's more coincidence. So the week after this episode aired, Apple revealed that you could now download episodes of the office onto these video iPods. Again, this was not planned. And then the office became the number.
iPod是苹果赞助的吗？不是的。我们说过它不是。这完全是个巧合。但还有更多的巧合。所以在这集播出后的一个星期，苹果宣布你现在可以把《办公室》的剧集下载到这些视频iPod上了。同样，这不是计划好的。然后《办公室》就成了排名
one downloaded show on iTunes. Yes. The number one downloaded show. I remember Rayne Wilson turned to me and said, I think we're going to make it. I think we're going to, this was the first moment. It felt like the tide was turning for us and that we might not get canceled. All right. So next up, Michael gets his gift, the oven mitt knitted by Phyllis. Now everyone had a $20 limit, you guys. That's why this iPod really shakes everything up because he spent $400. Yes. Yes. And he has his line where he says, I only, he says out in the hallway, he's holding the mitt. And he says, do you know what this says? This says, I only care about you a homemade oven mitt's worth. He is such a child. He is such a bratty kid in this episode. Oh my gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Chelsea, Raconza, and Amanda, and many others, actually, who actually knitted the oven mitt. Well, I asked Phyllis, she does not knit in real life. Although she told me that she knitted a scarf for her mom a couple of years ago, but she said that's it. She didn't, oh, just one scarf. I want you guys to know, you know how we talk about what was at everyone's
第一的iTunes下载节目。是的。排名第一的下载节目。我记得雷恩·威尔逊转向我说，我想我们要成功了。我想我们要，这是第一个时刻。感觉风向开始对我们有利了，我们可能不会被取消了。好吧。所以接下来，迈克尔得到了他的礼物，由菲利斯织的隔热手套。现在每个人都有20美元的限额，伙计们。这就是为什么这个iPod真正打破了一切平衡，因为他花了400美元。是的。是的。他有一句台词，他说，我只，他在走廊外面，拿着手套说。他说，你知道这说明了什么吗？这说明，我只在乎你值一个自制隔热手套那么多。他就像个孩子。他在这一集里就像个被宠坏的孩子。哦天哪。嗯，我们有一个来自切尔西、拉孔扎、阿曼达以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，实际上，到底是谁织的那个隔热手套？好吧，我问了菲利斯，她现实生活中不织毛织品。虽然她告诉我她几年前为她妈妈织过一条围巾，但她说仅此而已。她没有，哦，只织了一条围巾。我想让你们知道，你知道我们是怎么讨论每个人
desk? So at Phyllis's desk, like sitting on the floor sort of next to her desk for so many years was a whole knitting basket. Do you remember? It had all the yarn and the knitting needles and it sat there as if her character would ever do anything with it. But it was established there and it sat there. Well, Phil Shea told me he found a woman at a knitting store in Valley Village, California, and she knitted the oven mitt. Again, oven mitt knitter, if you're listening, please write us at OfficeLadies at Earwolf.com, and we'll give you a shout out. You knitted the famous mitt. I thought it looked like a great oven mitt, and it had like the little like a, like the Teflon-a-thony thingy on the one side. Yeah. Yeah. So Ryan gets the iPod, and at eight
办公桌上放着什么吗？所以在菲利斯的办公桌上，常年放在她桌子旁边地板上的，是一个完整的毛线篮。你们还记得吗？里面所有的纱线和织针就那样放着，仿佛她的角色会用它们做点什么似的。但它就摆在那里，一直放在那儿。好吧，菲尔·谢伊告诉我，他在加利福尼亚州山谷村的一家毛线店里找到了一位女士，她织了那个隔热手套。再次呼吁，隔热手套的编织者，如果你在听，请给我们写信，邮箱是OfficeLadies@earwolf.com，我们会对你大声致谢。你织了那个著名的手套。我觉得它看起来像个很棒的隔热手套，它在一侧还有那种特氟龙防烫的小玩意儿。是的。是的。所以瑞安得到了iPod，在8
minutes, 24 seconds is the next phase of Angela pissed offness. Okay. You see my face at the fact that Michael spent $400 when the limit was 20. All of my instructions, I'm sure I sent out an email about Secret Santa and the rules. So one, Phyllis has ignored my request for bigger lights and got the tiny lights. Now, two, Michael has spent $400 instead of the agreed upon $20. So we're ramping up. She's just getting ticked off. I have no doubt that you sent a very detailed email about this to everyone with a follow-up reminder. Mm-hmm.
分24秒时，是安吉拉气炸了的下一阶段。好吧。当迈克尔在限额20美元的情况下花了400美元时，你看我的表情。我所有的指示，我确信我发过一封关于秘密圣诞老人和规则的电子邮件。所以第一，菲利斯无视了我要求大灯的请求，买成了微型小灯。现在第二，迈克尔花了400美元，而不是约定好的20美元。所以我们在升级。她简直气炸了。毫无疑问，你向所有人发送了一封非常详细的电子邮件，并附有后续提醒。嗯哼。
Which is why Kevin does not come forward when he gets himself, because he would have had to tell me. He would have. Mm-hmm. Yeah. You know what? I really relate to Angela on so many levels. Listen.
这就是为什么凯文在给自己买礼物时不敢站出来，因为他那样的话就得告诉我。他确实得告诉我。嗯哼。你知道吗？我在很多方面都真的能跟安吉拉共情。听着。
Really do. On some levels, you're way more Angela than I am. Oh, yeah. I mean, I would have generated two, three, four very detailed emails about. the party, the plans. If I assign someone to do lights for the tree and that's what I got, I would feel so pissed and let down. If people went over the $20 budget, you would have been furious. Furious. Because you would have been like, what's the point? Why even have that number? Is Angela wrong? No, I don't think she's wrong. She's just, you know, why is no one helping her?
真的能。在某些方面，你比我更像安吉拉。哦，是的。我是说，我会为派对和计划写出两份、三份、四份非常详细的电子邮件。如果我指派某人去为圣诞树挂灯，结果得到的就是那个，我会感到非常气愤和失望。如果有人超出20美元的预算，你会气疯的。气疯。因为你会觉得，有什么意义？为什么还要设那个上限？安吉拉错了吗？不，我不认为她错了。她只是，你知道的，为什么没人帮她？
She's a buy-the-book person. Why can't people follow the rules? I agree. So at nine minutes, 39 seconds, she gets pissed off on a whole new level because, as you were saying, this is when Michael is really ticked off that he got the oven mitt and he switches the party. No more secret Santa. He says, now we're doing Yankee swap. Yes. Yankee swap slash white elephant slash, what was the other one he said?
她是个按规矩办事的人。为什么大家就不能遵守规则呢？我同意。所以在9分39秒时，她在一个全新的层面上气炸了，因为正如你所说，这就是迈克尔对收到隔热手套感到非常恼火并改变派对规则的时候。不再是秘密圣诞老人了。他说，现在我们玩洋基交换。是的。洋基交换斜杠白象斜杠，他说的另一个是什么来着？
Nasty Christmas. Nasty Christmas. You know, there was actually a little debate about. what do you call it? And people were like, well, we call it white elephant. And someone else was like, we call it Yankee Swap. And I feel like the writers took that and put it in the episode. Yeah, I know it as Yankee Swap. What do you know it as? I knew it as White Elephant. Yeah. I think it's good they did that. They covered everybody. They covered everybody. But when I threw my Christmas party, I called it Yankee Swap, just because I loved it so much.
讨厌的圣诞节。讨厌的圣诞节。你知道，关于叫什么名字其实有一场小小的争论。人们会说，嗯，我们叫它白象。而另一些人则说，我们叫它洋基交换。我觉得编剧们采纳了这一点并把它写进了剧集里。是的，我知道它叫洋基交换。你们叫它什么？我叫它白象。是的。我觉得他们这么做挺好的。他们照顾到了所有人。他们照顾到了所有人。但当我办圣诞派对时，我叫它洋基交换，只因为我太喜欢这个名字了。
You know, here's something that I heard in the commentary, Angela, since we're talking about your character. I guess that you had a talking head in the fire. I watched it. it because I have a DVD player now in the deleted scenes. Well, Mike said that the writer's room was so impressed with your performance in that talking head that they put a card on the wall that was Angela cries and they wanted to find an episode where you could cry a bunch and this was it. Mike sure told me, he said, I love to see your character cry. He said she's so pulled together that when you sort of fall apart, it's like really sort of oddly pleasing. Oh, I love it. I love it. So yes, at 9 minutes, 51 seconds, I have a talking head. And my character
你知道，安吉拉，既然我们在讨论你的角色，我在评论音轨里听到了一件事。我猜你有一段独白是在火灾里。我看过了。我看过了，因为我有了DVD播放机，在被删减的镜头里。嗯，迈克说编剧室对你在那段独白中的表现印象深刻，以至于他们在墙上贴了一张卡片，上面写着“安吉拉哭了”，他们想找一集能让你大哭特哭的剧集，而这就是这一集。迈克·舒尔告诉我，他说，我喜欢看你的角色哭。他说她平时太拿腔作调了，所以当你有点崩溃时，感觉真的很奇妙地令人愉悦。哦，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。所以，是的，在9分51秒时，我有一段独白。我的角色
is really upset because she feels like Michael should have talked to the PPC first. Yeah. Well, they should have. And then she breaks down. So she is really starting to spiral. And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing. I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying. She's sullen. She's very sullen. Okay, you know this famous line, Yankee Swap. Yeah. From Michael.
真的很难过，因为她觉得迈克尔应该先跟PPC商量。是的。嗯，他们本来应该的。然后她崩溃了。所以她真的开始情绪失控了。然后当我们切回场景时，她还在哭泣。我是说，她不是号啕大哭，但她仍在哭。她闷闷不乐。她非常阴郁。好了，你知道这句著名的台词，洋基交换。是的。来自迈克尔。
All right. Mike Scher, that's a written line. That wasn't improvised that Steve would say Yankee Swap. And Mike wrote in the script, in parentheses, crazy voice. And he was like, I know Steve will do something great with that. And that was Steve's take on that. Because they would do that. They would sometimes put little pieces of direction in the script for us.
好吧。迈克·舒尔，那是剧本写出来的台词。并不是史蒂夫说“洋基交换”是即兴发挥的。迈克在剧本里写了，在括号里写着：疯狂的嗓音。他当时想，我知道史蒂夫会用这个发挥得很棒。那是史蒂夫对那句台词的演绎。因为他们会那样做。他们有时会在剧本里为我们写一点表演方向的小提示，
and then we'd have to interpret it. Yeah. Guys, did you notice in this episode, it is snowing outside? I loved this touch. I loved that they kept cutting to the windows and there'd be snow. Do you remember how much fun it was to have the snow? We were so tickled by the snow. We were so excited.
然后我们必须去诠释它。伙计们，你们注意到这一集里外面在下雪吗？我喜欢这个细节。我喜欢他们不断切到窗户的镜头，外面都在下雪。你们还记得下雪有多好玩吗？我们对雪感到无比好笑。我们太兴奋了。
You guys remember we mostly just filmed inside and we never even saw outside or what was happening outside. Yeah. And so the fact that we had this extra element happening was so fun. We really did film inside in a windowless warehouse. All the windows were fake. They just had backdrops behind them. So to see actual sunshine or snow or air was really exciting to us.
你们还记得我们大部分都是在室内拍摄的，甚至从来没有看到过外面或者外面发生了什么。对啊。所以有这个额外的元素加入进来真的太有趣了。我们确实是在一个没有窗户的仓库里拍摄的。所有的窗户都是假的。后面只是挂着背景幕。所以能看到真正的阳光、雪或空气，对我们来说真的非常兴奋。
I have a ton of facts about the snow. I don't know if anyone else will find it interesting, but I had written all about it in one of my blogs slash journals. I'm living for this. I can't wait to hear about it. I do have to pee. Oh, do you want me to give you some snow facts when we come back from the break? I mean, can I go pee?
我有很多关于雪的冷知识。我不知道别人会不会觉得有趣，但我把这些都写在了我的博客兼日记里。我太期待这个了。我等不及要听了。我其实得去上个洗手间。哦，等我们休息回来，你想让我跟你讲讲关于雪的事吗？我是说，我能去上个厕所吗？
You should be on an empty bladder when I lay these awesome facts on you. You don't tell me or my bladder what we're doing. Well, what do you want? Do you want full bladder snow facts or empty bladder snow facts? I want empty bladder snow facts. All right, that's what I'm saying. Oh, I thought you were telling me that I had to not drink any more water or tea. When we go on a road trip, my husband will be like, can you not get an ice tea?
当我把这些超赞的冷知识传授给你时，你的膀胱最好是空的。你别来指挥我和我的膀胱该做什么。好吧，你想怎样？你是想要满膀胱的雪的冷知识，还是空膀胱的雪的冷知识？我想要空膀胱的雪的冷知识。好吧，我就是这个意思。哦，我还以为你在命令我以后不准再喝水或茶了呢。每次我们去公路旅行，我丈夫就会说，你能不能别喝冰茶？
Okay, clearly you're projecting some other thing on me because I said I thought you should empty your bladder for the snow facts. She's leaving. First, you push away from the mic to eat your, your, your, snack. This is for you, Jenna. So disgust. Love our honeynut Cheerios. Oh, God. Thank you for letting me have my bathroom break. I want to hear all about
好了，很明显你把别的什么情绪投射到我身上了，因为我刚才说我V觉得你应该为了听雪的冷知识先把膀胱排空。她要走了。首先，你把麦克风推开去吃你的、你的、你的零食。这是给你的，珍娜。真恶心。我太爱我们的蜂蜜坚果麦圈了。天哪。谢谢你们让我去上洗手间。我想听听所有关于
your snow. All right. I hope this is an anticlimactic for people, but the company that came to make the snow is called snow business. I love that. Snow business. I remembered. I remembered that. It's so tickled me. Okay, so here's how it works with fake snow. There's a guy from snow business. He shows up. Now, the snow that falls from the sky is different from the ground cover snow. The snow on the ground is snow. The snow that falls from the sky, I know because it falls on my character at the end, and it is not snow. It's not snow. It's soap. Yes. You can get a choice. You can get a choice of cornstarch, plastic, or soap.
你的雪的事。好吧。希望这对大家来说不会觉得反高潮，但那家来造雪的公司叫“雪业”（Snow Business）。我太喜欢这个名字了。雪业。我记起来了。我记起来了。这太让我开心了。好吧，假雪是这样运作的。有一个来自“雪业”公司的家伙。他出现了。现在，从天上飘落的雪和地上的积雪是不一样的。地上的雪就是雪。从天上落下来的雪——我知道是因为最后它落在了我扮演的角色身上——它根本不是雪。它不是雪。是肥皂。是的。你有得选。你可以选择玉米淀粉、塑料或肥皂。
And Greg watched a demonstration of all three, and he picked soap. Well, when by accident a little piece of that might get in your mouth, it tastes like soap. Because I shriek, and a piece of it went in my mouth. That's what? Yeah. She said. Yeah. Yeah.
格雷格看了一场这三种材质的演示，然后他选了肥皂。结果，当偶尔有一小块那东西不小心进到你嘴里时，它尝起来就像肥皂。因为我尖叫了一声，然后一块那东西就掉进了我嘴里。是吗？对。她说。对。对。
Okay. On the ground, though, it's real snow. And they bring this machine, and I don't know exactly how it works, but it's kind of like, like a wood chipper, but in it in reverse. It looks like something out of a Dr. Seuss. It does. It really does. And it really blows snow. I guess that's what it looks like.
不过，地上的雪是真的雪。他们推来一台机器，我不太清楚它具体是怎么运作的，但它有点像、像一台木材粉碎机，不过是倒转过来的。它看起来就像苏斯博士书里走出来的东西。确实。真的太像了。而且它真的能吹出雪。我想这就是它看起来的样子。
It looks like a snowblower, but it generates snow. And then it just blows it all over the ground, all over the cars and all that stuff. But guys, remember, this is like, we're shooting this in like October in Los Angeles. And it's hot in October. It stays warm here. Yeah. In the daytime, it's still in the mid-80s, 90s. But it was night.
它看起来像一台吹雪机，但它能制造雪。然后它就把雪吹得到处都是，满地都是，车上也是，还有各种地方。但是大家记住，这就像是我们在洛杉矶十月份的时候拍的。十月份很热。这里一直很暖和。对啊。白天的时候，气温仍然在八十几度到九十度之间。但那是晚上。
And so we had a little bit of time with it. I mean, it was still warm out. Yeah, it was probably like in the high 60s. Yeah. That sounds about right. But yes, we were very excited to have snow. And Jenna, we're... Did you like my snow facts?
所以我们只有一点时间能用上它。我是说，外面其实还是暖和的。对，大概有六十多度快七十度的样子。对，差不多是这样。但是，是的，能有雪我们非常激动。而且，珍娜，我们……你喜欢我的雪冷知识吗？
I feel a little vulnerable about them now because we set them up so much. I mean, there was like a break and in my head about it. I like your snow facts. Snow business. That's cute. I think snow business is really cute. All right. But let's go back to the gift exchange.
我现在对它们有点没底了，因为我们之前铺垫了那么多。我是说，中间还隔了一段休息，我脑子里一直在想这事。我喜欢你的雪冷知识。“雪业”。真可爱。我觉得“雪业”这个名字真的好可爱。好吧。不过我们还是回到礼物交换环节吧。
This is when Kelly gets Angela's poster. But, Angela, you do get to take it back. Okay, here's the thing. I wrote in my MySpace blog about this moment. And I wrote that it was one of the hardest things for us to get through as a cast that the first time Mindy unrolls the poster and looks at it. and we all see it. We all, every person lost it. Because it's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous. We had not seen it. It was an actual surprise to us while we were filming and we all lost it. I had that in fact,
这就是凯莉拿到安吉拉海报的时候。但是，安吉拉，你确实把它要回来了。好吧，事情是这样的。我在我的MySpace博客上写过这个时刻。我写道，这是我们作为演员最难熬过去的时刻之一，那就是明迪第一次展开海报并看着它的那一刻。我们所有人都看到了。我们所有人都、每一个人都彻底笑喷了。因为太荒谬了。简直太荒谬了。我们之前没看过。我们在拍摄时完全是个惊喜，我们所有人全都笑崩了。事实上我当时，
it was particularly hard on rain for some reason. And that in one take, he broke three times because he could not get through it. I can't believe that Mindy was tasked with having to unroll that poster how did we ever get a shot of her not laughing i don't know but we were cracking up there's a little detail in that scene that made me laugh when i rewatched it which is how you you just very subtly swat the oven mitt away on your way to getting the poster that was all me thank you very much i loved it it was such a good detail i loved it um well in tracking the oven mitt Meredith eventually takes the oven mitt. But, you know, Michael has to then call her a sucker and say that he wanted her to take it. And it was reverse psychology when he said he wanted to keep it. I love that he decided that he needed to break down reverse psychology to all of us. Because I don't know if you've heard of it. This is a pretty cool thing. I'm like, Michael, you're such an idiot. Do you remember how Phyllis cried during that scene? Yeah, she stayed in like sort of that. sad place. She cried for like a half hour and in between takes of that where she had to be
不知为什么，这尤其是难为了雷恩。在其中一个镜头里，他NG了三次，因为他根本无法演下去。我简直不敢相信明迪居然忍着不笑把那张海报展开了，我们到底是怎么拍到她没笑的镜头的？我不知道，但当时我们真的快笑疯了。那个场景里有个小细节，我重看的时候把我逗笑了，就是你在去拿海报的路上，非常顺手地把烤箱手套给拍开的那个动作。那全是我即兴的，非常感谢。我太喜欢了，这是一个绝佳的细节，我爱死它了。嗯，说到这只烤箱手套的去向，梅雷迪思最后拿走了这只烤箱手套。但是，你知道的，迈克尔随后必须叫她“冤大头”，并说他本来就希望她拿走。当他说他想留着它时，其实用的是反向心理学。我很喜欢他决定要给我们所有人详细剖析一下什么是反向心理学。因为我不知道你们有没有听说过这个词。这可是个相当厉害的概念呢。我当时就想，迈克尔，你真是个大笨蛋。你们还记得菲莉丝在那场戏里是怎么哭的吗？对，她一直沉浸在那种悲伤的情绪里。她哭了大概半个小时，在那些需要她哭泣的镜头拍摄间隙里，
crying. She didn't want any of us to talk to her. And Kate and I tried to go up and give her a hug. She didn't want it. Like she was in this like actor zone. It's so hard to do. It's so hard to do. I know exactly where she was, but I just remember being really worried for her because when you see Phyllis cry, it is, ugh. You don't want to see Phyllis cry because it breaks every part of you open. I mean, I mean, she did, she wanted, she had to stay sad. And it is really hard, especially sitting in this circle with people cracking up about a baby poster.
她不希望我们任何人跟她说话。凯特和我试图走过去给她一个拥抱。她根本不接受。她当时完全进入了一种“演员专属状态”。这太难做到了。这真的太难了。我完全理解她当时的状态，但我只记得当时真的很替她担心，因为当你看到菲莉丝哭的时候，那种感觉，呃。你真的不想看到菲莉丝哭，因为那会把你的心碎成好几瓣。我是说，我是说，她确实、她想要、她必须保持悲伤。这真的很难，特别是当大家正围坐在一起，为一个婴儿海报笑得前仰后合的时候。
Yeah. But you've got to stay sad. Yes. It's hard. It's really hard. That is very difficult. Well, here's the thing. Michael just gets progressively meaner, you know, he calls Meredith a sucker.
对啊。但你必须保持悲伤。没错。这很难。真的很难。那真的非常困难。好吧，事情是这样的。迈克尔变得越来越刻薄，你知道的，他叫梅雷迪思“冤大头”。
And then Dwight, you know, he opens the paintball. And he's like, you know, how is this better than an iPod? And this moment kind of broke my heart, too, when Dwight goes, I never said it was better, you know? Wait, I have an Angela pissed off in this moment. Oh, okay, go. At 13 minutes, 58 seconds, look at my face. I wrote it in all caps. So Michael has just called Meredith a sucker because she got the lame, you know, oven mitt.
然后德怀特，你知道的，他打开了彩弹枪。然后他说，你知道的，这怎么能比iPod好呢？这个时刻也差不多伤透了我的心，当德怀特说，我从来没说过它更好，你知道吗？等等，我有一个安吉拉在这个时刻气炸的瞬间。哦，好吧，说吧。在13分58秒的时候，看我的脸。我是用全大写字母写的。迈克尔刚刚叫梅雷迪思“冤大头”，因为她拿到了那个逊毙的、你知道的，烤箱手套。
And Phyllis storms out, okay? She is completely heartbroken now. And the party is falling apart. and the look on my face is just sheer and like rage. Now, are we at the top of your rage now? No. Oh, no. Well, I mean, I know we've still got the parking lot, but.
然后菲莉丝气冲冲地夺门而出，好吧？她现在彻底心碎了。派对正在分崩离析。而我脸上的表情简直就是纯粹的、无尽的愤怒。现在，我们已经达到你愤怒的巅峰了吗？没有。哦，没有。好吧，我是说，我知道我们还有停车场那段，但是。
No. Oh, no. There's a moment coming and you'll know it. It's the, there's a one-two punch coming at the end for my anger. But yeah. All right. So people are making trades and feelings are getting hurt. Yeah.
没有。哦，不。接下来有个高潮时刻，你们一看就会知道。为了我的愤怒，最后会有一记组合拳。不过，是的。好吧。所以大家都在换礼物，而且感情也受到了伤害。对啊。
And Pam does not go back and get the teapot. she gets the iPod. She does. When it's Pam's turn to pick again, she picks the iPod instead of the teapot. And Jim is so hurt. He's so hurt. And I, you know, I watched this and I was like, come on, Pam. But then, you know, Pam doesn't know what all is in the teapot. She doesn't. And that's what sort of justified it for me. She's just like, this is an iPod. This iPod has completely hijacked this whole fun party and gift exchange because everybody who's sitting in the seat is just thinking about trying to get the iPod. And so is Pam. Unfortunately, I think she kind of forgot about the teapot. So it was her time to pick. She was just like, iPod. But she also doesn't know what's in the teapot. She doesn't. She doesn't know how high the stakes are for Jim. No. She doesn't. I think it's kind of an innocent moment, honestly. And Michael has ruined all of this because the gifts were specific for people. I mean, Ryan gets a placard that says Kelly. Yeah. He gets like, you know, a desk, whatever, nameplate. Yeah. Like, these were not meant to be Yankee swap gifts.
而帕姆并没有回去拿茶壶。她拿了iPod。她确实拿了。轮到帕姆再次挑选时，她选了iPod而不是茶壶。吉姆感到非常受伤。他太受伤了。而我，你知道的，我看到这里时就想，拜托，帕姆。但随后，你知道的，帕姆并不知道茶壶里装了什么。她不知道。这就是为什么我觉得这对我来说情有可原。她当时就想，这是一个iPod。这个iPod彻底毁了这个有趣的派对和礼物交换，因为所有坐在座位上的人满脑子都只想著怎么拿到iPod。帕姆也是如此。不幸的是，我觉得她有点把茶壶给忘了。所以轮到她选的时候，她脑子里只有：iPod。但她也不知道茶壶里有什么。她确实不知道。她不知道这对吉姆来说赌注有多大。不，她不知道。老实说，我觉得这算是一个挺天真的时刻。而且迈克尔把这一切都毁了，因为这些礼物本来就是专门为特定的人准备的。我是说，瑞恩收到了一个写着“凯莉”的桌牌。对。他收到了一个、你知道的，桌子上的什么铭牌。对。这些本来就不是为了玩“洋基交换”而准备的。
were not. They were meant for certain people. Well, at this point, the party has completely broken down and Michael goes to the liquor store. Now, I want to point out a few things. I know what you're going to point out because, lady, I have the DVDs now. So go, do it? Do you know what I'm going to say? Is it about the attendant at the liquor store? I have one thing to say about him, but I just thought I wanted to point out that it's also snowing outside the window of the liquor store. Yeah. They made it snow there too. I don't know. Nice detail. Nice touch. Good continuity. Veda was on it. Well, I read that our rioters found out in Pennsylvania that if you work at a liquor store, you have to wear a tie. Yes. And so that was part of this character description is that he had to have on a tie. Isn't that great?
本来就不是。它们是送给特定之人的。好吧，到了这个时候，派对已经彻底失控了，迈克尔去了酒品专卖店。现在，我想指出几件事。我知道你要指出什么，因为，亲爱的，我现在有DVD了。所以，说吧，做吧！你知道我要说什么吗？是关于酒品专卖店店员的事吗？关于他我有一句话要说，但我只是觉得我想指出，在酒品专卖店的窗户外面其实也在下雪。对啊。他们连那里也造了雪。我不知道。不错的细节。很好的点触。连贯性很好。维达做得很到位。好吧，我读到我们的剧组人员在宾夕法尼亚州发现，如果你在酒品专卖店工作，你就必须系领带。是的。所以这也是这个角色设定的一部分，那就是他必须系领带。这不是很棒吗？
And I thought the actor, his name is Ryan Martin. Did a fantastic job. He just really like takes in all of that vodka. Fifteen bottles. Fifteen bottles. craziness. Okay. So then we go back to the party. Michael brings all this vodka back into the party and at 16, 10 minutes. This is the next phase of Angela. Angela's spiral. Oh, say it. So Michael has vodka. And she's like, what are you doing? There's no alcohol at the party. You know, Angela speaks up and Toby speaks up. No one else cares. But now she's like, Toby speaks up. I missed that. Yeah. Toby's like, Michael, we really shouldn't have. And he goes, just shut it, Toby.
而且我觉得那个演员，他叫瑞恩·马丁。表现得太棒了。他真的把所有的伏特加都包下了。十五瓶。十五瓶。太疯狂了。好吧。然后我们回到了派对上。迈克尔把所有这些伏特加带回了派对，在16分10秒的时候。这是安吉拉抓狂的下一个阶段。哦，说吧。所以迈克尔带了伏特加。而她就说，你在干什么？派对上没有酒。你知道的，安吉拉开口了，托比也开口了。没人在乎。但现在她变成了：托比也开口了。我漏掉了这个。对啊。托比说，迈克尔，我们真不该这样。然后他说，闭嘴吧，托比。
It's a party. But then later, I feel like Toby brings Todd Packer a drink. Well, no, it's all, like, all bets are off at this point. And, you know, you have to remember that Michael told the party planning committee that he wanted this Christmas party to be like, and I quote, a Playboy Mansion party. Yeah. That was his hope. That's his goal.
这只是个派对。但后来，我觉得托比给托德·帕克递了一杯酒。好吧，不，这完全是、在这个时候所有的规矩都形同虚设了。而且，你知道的，你得记住，迈克尔曾对派对策划委员会说过，他希望这个圣诞派对办得像，我引述一下，“花花公子俱乐部派对”。对。那是他的期望。那是他的目标。
That's his goal. So, but yeah, Angela is now super ticked because now there's alcohol. I'm surprised her whole head didn't explode. Well, it's about to, because the next two are what set it into motion. Oh, boy. Well, now we have the scene where Jim is trying to get the teapot back from Dwight. Jim offers to trade him the shamrock keychain, and he says, come on, it'll be good luck. And that's when Dwight has his line.
那是他的目标。所以，但是，是的，安吉拉现在超级抓狂，因为现在有酒了。我很惊讶她的整个脑袋竟然没有当场爆炸。好吧，它快要爆炸了，因为接下来的两件事才是导火索。哦，天哪。好吧，现在我们来到这个场景：吉姆正试图从德怀特那里把茶壶拿回来。吉姆主动提出用三叶草钥匙扣跟他交换，并且他说，得了吧，这会带来好运的。然后德怀特就说出了那句台词。
A real man makes his own luck, Billy Zane, Titanic, and Angela. You made the entire cast T-shirts with that quote on them, and I still have mine. Oh my gosh, you do. I do. It's a gray long-sleeve t-shirt. Yes, with black writing. Just a quote across it. Yeah.
“真正的男人创造自己的幸运”——比利·赞恩，《泰坦尼克号》，还有安吉拉。你给整个剧组定制了印有这句名言的T恤，我现在还留着呢。哦天哪，你真的留着。我留着呢。那是一件灰色的长袖T恤。是的，上面印着黑色的字。胸前就印着那句台词。对啊。
So I had a friend at the time who had a t-shirt press because she had a small business. And I loved this line so much. I thought it was hilarious of all people for Dwight to quote. It would be Billy Zane. Well, people were asking if we gave each other gifts. That was a gift. You gave that out. I think you actually gave that out at Christmas that year.
所以当时我有一个朋友开着一家小公司，她有一台T恤印花机。我太喜欢这句台词了。我觉得由德怀特说出这样的话简直太搞笑了。居然会是比利·赞恩。好吧，大家都在问我们是不是互赠了礼物。那本身就是一件礼物。那是你送出的礼物。我觉得那年圣诞节你确实把它当礼物送出去了。
I did. And you gave everyone an ornament. Yes. I got that cast photo and I had it printed on an ornament for everyone. Yeah. Aw. The idea that Dwight wants to keep the teapot in order to wash out his nasal passages with green tea is based on something that Greg Daniels has actually done. Like with a netty pot?
我是送了。而且你送了每个人一个装饰品。对。我拿到了那张剧组合影，并把它印成了每个人专属的圣诞树装饰品。呀。太温馨了。德怀特想要留着茶壶以便用绿茶来冲洗鼻腔这个情节，是根据格雷格·丹尼尔斯自己实际做过的事改编的。就像用洗鼻壶那样？
Yeah, I mean, but I've never put green tea in a nutty pot. I haven't either. I've only used the saline solution that is recommended. But I could see Greg reading about it and giving it a try. But Rain, the way Rain was in that scene. And he, like, shoved that teapot into his nostril. Yeah. And just John's face's gym is just like, are you kidding me?
对，我是说，但我从来没在洗鼻壶里放过绿茶。我也没有。我只用过推荐的生理盐水溶液。但我能想象格雷格读到过这个然后去尝试了一下。不过，雷恩，雷恩在那个场景里的表现。他竟然把那个茶壶塞进鼻孔里。对啊。而吉姆的表情简直就是：你在开玩笑吗？
That's who gets my teapot? Like, it's so perfect. He's so bummed. Now, when I watched this with Lee, Lee said he wondered how Dwight didn't find the note in the box. Or how Dwight didn't open up the teapot. I thought of all of those things. I thought Dwight now has the cassette and the sauce packet. I mean, so you have to sort of suspend belief, I guess, at that moment that he took those out and just shoved him aside.
这就是拿走我茶壶的人？天哪，太完美了。他太沮丧了。现在，当我跟李一起看这一集时，李说他很好奇德怀特怎么会没发现盒子里的纸条。或者德怀特怎么会没打开茶壶看看。我把这些都想到了。我想德怀特现在拿着磁带和酱料包。所以，我是说，你在这个时候不得不暂时放弃理智，去相信他只是把这些东西拿出来然后随手扔在一边。
Like, hmm, what's this crap? And just sort of shoved him aside in the box? Well, also, I don't think Jim is trying to get the teapot back for Pam. I think he's just trying to get the teapot back for himself. He's just going to keep it now. That's what I think the motivation is there because Pam is over. you know, up at the desk with Roy looking through her new iPod. I think Jim just wants to get it back because I think there's things inside it that are embarrassing.
就好像，嗯，这是什么垃圾？然后顺手把它们扔在盒子的一边？好吧，而且，我觉得吉姆当时不是为了帕姆才想把茶壶拿回来的。我觉得他只是为了他自己才想拿回茶壶的。他现在打算把它留着了。我觉得这就是当时的动机，因为帕姆正。你知道的，正坐在前台那边和罗伊一起翻看她的新iPod。我觉得吉姆只是想把它拿回来，因为我觉得里面有些东西挺尴尬的。
Yes, exactly. But he's going to trade the keychain and he's just going to take that teapot home now. So Pam is up at reception and she's showing Roy her new iPod. He's now at the party. He wasn't there for Yankee swap. But he's all excited because now he doesn't have to buy it for Pam for Christmas. He was going to buy her this iPod, he tells her. And now he doesn't have to or he's just going to get her a sweater.
是的，完全没错。但他是打算用钥匙扣去换，然后直接把那个茶壶带回家。所以帕姆在前台那边，正在向罗伊展示她的新iPod。他现在也在派对上了。他之前“洋基交换”时不在。但他现在兴奋极了，因为他不用再为帕姆买圣诞礼物了。他本来打算给她买这个iPod的，他告诉她。现在他不用买了，或者他打算随便给她买件毛衣。
Thanks, Roy. Now the party is like 15 bottles of vodka in. Todd Packer has showed up. Oh, yeah. It's getting crazy. And everyone's doing shots. Angela's fuming. I am fuming, but the icing on the cake of my pissed offness is about to happen. Oh, say it. Michael shouts to the whole bullpen. He says, oh, my gosh. Yes, Ryan, the king of the party planning. Oh. Thank you to, thank you to Ryan for this awesome party. and the camera pans to me, and I am livid. Ryan the temp, the king of the party planning committee? Are you kidding me? Yeah. Oh, that's it. She is pissed.
谢谢你，罗伊。现在派对上差不多喝掉了15瓶伏特加。托德·帕克也出现了。哦，是的。现场开始疯狂了。每个人都在干杯。安吉拉气急败坏。我在气急败坏，不过我怒火中烧的“蛋糕上的糖霜”马上就要发生了。哦，说吧。迈克尔朝着整个大办公室大喊。他说，哦，天哪。太棒了，瑞恩，派对策划之王。哦。感谢、感谢瑞恩带来了这个棒极了的派对。然后镜头摇向了我，我当时气得面色铁青。瑞恩这个临时工，竟然成了派对策划委员会之王？你在开玩笑吗？对啊。哦，就是这样。她气炸了。
Oh, no. And it's only going to get worse. That's not even still the worst thing that's happened to Angela. Nope. I had a headache by the end of this episode. You must have. You were just scowling and pushing anger out of your temples this whole episode. You know when Todd Packer shows up and he has that line,
哦，不。而且情况只会变得更糟。这甚至还不是安吉拉遇到的最糟糕的事。不。这一集看下来我都头疼了。你肯定头疼。你整集都在板着脸，太阳穴都快气得冒烟了。你知道当托德·帕克出现时，他有那句台词，
What's up, my nerds? My nerds. That was an improv, sort of. In the script, what was written was, what's up nerds. And he just gave it that extra special touch of what's up my nerds. I know. Well, that's also Dave Kekner. I mean, I think even the line when he's like,
“怎么啦，我的书呆子们？”我的书呆子们。那算是即兴发挥。剧本里原本写的台词是，怎么啦书呆子们。而他只是加上了“我的”这个非常特别的修饰，变成了“怎么啦我的书呆子们”。我知道。好吧，那也是戴夫·凯克纳的风格。我是说，我觉得甚至当他说，
Packer need a drinkie. Yeah. The line was probably like he was getting me a drink. Yeah. You know. He brought so much to that role. It was amazing. Well, you know when he has to lay down on the desk and get the silly string on him, like when he
“帕克需要来杯酒吗？”对。那句台词大概就像是他在帮我拿酒一样。对。你知道的。他为那个角色注入了太多东西。简直太棒了。好吧，你知道当他不得不躺在桌子上，身上被喷满了疯狂彩带的时候，就像他
passes out? I remember shooting that. He had to lay there forever. So he laid down on those desks, which were not comfortable, right? And then they silly stringed his head. And then we had all these scenes where that's what he's doing. Well, if he got up, all the stuff that he was decorated in would have fallen off, it would have been impossible to recreate.
昏迷过去的那样？我记得当时拍这场戏的情形。他必须在上面躺超级久。所以他躺在那些桌子上，那些桌子其实一点也不舒服，对吧？然后他们把疯狂彩带喷在他头上。接着我们所有的场景里他都在做这个。好吧，如果他站起来，他身上那些装饰品全都会掉下来，那就根本不可能再还原了。
So he had to just lay there, even when we were on a break. even when we were on a break and he was such a trooper talk about a trooper and i wrote in my my space blog that kate and i because kate and i knew dave from improv days we had all like done improv shows together that kate and i walked over and talked to him while he had to lay on his back and we just sort of like caught up and that it was so fun to see him but i want you guys to know if you're wondering what todd packer looks like at 20 minutes 19 seconds to really paint a picture here yeah he's laying on his back kind of across a desk area partition, right, in the middle of the room. He has blue silly string on his head, Christmas lights around his torso, Christmas garland around his torso, Dwight's desk nameplate on his stomach, and there's like a red, empty solo cup kind of just like in his, like the crook of his arm. And he had to lay like that with all those things on top of him.
所以他只能一直躺在那儿，甚至在我们休息的时候也是。甚至在我们休息的时候也是，而且他真的特别敬业，说到敬业的话。我在我的MySpace博客上写过，因为凯特和我——因为凯特和我以前在即兴表演时期就认识戴夫，我们所有人以前一起做过即兴表演秀——凯特和我走过去跟他聊天，当时他正不得不躺在背上，我们就随便聊了聊，叙了叙旧，能看到他真的太好玩了。但我想要你们知道，如果你好奇托德·帕克在20分19秒时是什么样子的话，为了在这里给你们描绘一幅画面，对，他正仰面躺着，横跨在一个办公区的隔板上，对吧，就在房间正中间。他头上挂着蓝色的疯狂彩带，躯干上缠着圣诞彩灯，躯干上还围着圣诞花环，德怀特的桌上名牌放在他的肚皮上，还有一个红色的空塑料红杯，就那样卡在他的、他手臂的弯儿里。他不得不带着所有这些东西压在身上，就这样一直躺着。
He passes out so quickly. You have to imagine he showed up already half drunk. You know he did. You know he did. You know he did. Okay, guys, so now we have the scene where Pam reveals to Jim that she got her teapot back. She trades Dwight, the iPod for the teapot, and now she's going to look inside and find all the items. And it's very charming and sweet, and she is so delighted.
他晕倒得太快了。你肯定能想象他出现的时候就已经喝了半醉了。你知道他肯定是这样的。你知道是的。你知道是的。好了，各位，现在我们来到这个场景，帕姆向吉姆透露她拿回了她的茶壶。她用Dwight、iPod换了茶壶，现在她要看里面并找到所有的东西。这非常迷人且甜蜜，她高兴极了。
But in this moment, Jim secretly steals the note back and puts it. it in his pocket. I know. He lost his courage. He did. Now, when we reached out to fans to ask them what they wanted to know about the Christmas episode, I would say that about 80% of the comments and emails we received were along the lines of what is in the teapot note. Because as you know, in this episode, Pam does not read it. It is not revealed. But then, in season nine, there's a scene where Jim has the documentary film crew put together footage of their romance and he shows it to Pam and Pam sees that there was a note that Jim steals back and then he hands it to her and she reads it. How brilliant is that? And you know who that is? That's Greg Daniels. Yeah.
但在这一刻，吉姆偷偷把便条拿了回来，把它放进了口袋里。我知道。他失去了勇气。他确实是。现在，当我们联系粉丝，询问他们想了解关于这集圣诞节什么的，我想我们收到的评论和电子邮件中大约有80%都是关于茶壶便条里写了什么。因为如你所知，在这集中，帕姆并没有读它。它没有被揭晓。但是，在第九季中，有一个场景，吉姆让纪录片摄制组把他们浪漫的镜头剪辑在一起，他把它给帕姆看，帕姆看到有一张便条是吉姆拿回来的，然后他把它递给她，她读了。这有多棒？你知道那是谁吗？那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的。
Because he was such a master at beautiful callback moments. I love that. Well, from the time that Jim stole the note, it drove people crazy. They always wanted to know. know what had been written in the note, would Pam ever get the note? For years and years, will he ever give her the note? Around the time of the wedding, people wanted him to give it to her as a wedding gift. Greg saved it till the end. I'm going to say something that I've never said before. I also feel like I'm maybe going to cry. What? Wait. Wait. What? Are you going to say what was in the note? Are you going to say what was in the note? Sort of. Because I don't know what was on that card.
因为他是制作美好回忆杀的高手。我喜欢那个。好吧，从吉姆偷走便条的那一刻起，人们就快疯了。他们总是想知道。便条上写了什么，帕姆会拿到便条吗？多年来，他会把便条给她吗？在婚礼前后，人们希望他把它作为结婚礼物送给她。格雷格把它留到了最后。我要说一些我从未说过的话。我也觉得自己可能要哭了。什么？等等。等等。什么？你要说便条里写了什么吗？你要说便条里写了什么吗？算是吧。因为我不知道那张卡片上写了什么。
None of us do. I'm the only one who knows and John knows. Oh my gosh, lady. In that episode in season nine, I believe Greg suggested to John that he write a personal message from himself to me just saying what our time together on the office meant to him. Oh, Jenna. Because we were wrapping up filming.
我们谁也不知道。只有我知道，约翰也知道。哦天哪，蕾迪。在第九季的那集中，我相信格雷格建议约翰写一条他自己给我的私人信息，只说我们在办公室一起度过的时光对意味着什么。哦，珍娜。因为我们快拍完了。
We were wrapping up the series, and we were all so emotional at that time, you know? It was all, we were all sort of saying goodbye in different ways. We were. And so that was his goodbye. Very similar to when we film that scene with Steve, where I said goodbye to him at the airport, and Paul Feig told me, just run up and say goodbye to your friend, Steve. Jeff Blitz said the same thing to me when I was in the car with Oscar and I say I love Dwight
我们正在拍摄该系列的尾声，那时候我们都百感交集，你知道吗？总之，我们都在以不同的方式说再见。我们是的。所以那是他的告别。这非常类似于我们和史蒂夫拍摄的那场戏，我在机场向他道别，保罗·费格告诉我，直接跑过去和你的朋友史蒂夫说再见。杰夫·布里茨在我和奥斯卡在车里，我说我爱德怀特时也对我说过同样的话
he said Angela in this moment express your love for the show and everyone and if you couldn't have it in your life anymore and I disintegrated Yeah so I'm on camera and I open up this note
他说，安吉拉，此时此刻，表达你对这个节目和每个人的爱，如果你再也不能在你的生活中拥有它，我崩溃了，是的，所以我在镜头前打开了这个便条
that John's written me and I just start crying I just start bawling It probably, the first take was probably not usable. It was the sweetest note. And, you know, on camera, Pam says, I'll never say what it said, but just know it was perfect. Well, I'll never say exactly what John wrote, but I will say, just know it was perfect. So that's what was in the teapot note, guys.
约翰写给我的，我开始哭泣，我开始大哭。这可能，第一个镜头可能没法用。这是最甜蜜的便条。而且，你知道，在镜头前，帕姆说，我永远不会说上面写了什么，但只要知道它是完美的。好吧，我永远不会说约翰确切写了什么，但我会说，只要知道它是完美的。所以这就是茶壶便条里的内容，伙计们。
It was a, it was a note from John to me. A personal note about what it meant to work with you on the show. Yeah, about our time together on the show. And it was really sweet. Well, that would completely wreck me. Yeah. Oh, I love that. I didn't know that. Are you okay? Yeah. Well, crap, how do we talk about anything else? That was so beautiful. I'm sorry. That was so beautiful. I love that that was the direction that Greg gave. Those moments became very honest for us under that kind of direction.
这是一张，约翰写给我的便条。一张关于在节目中与你共事意味着什么的个人便条。是的，关于我们在节目中一起度过的时光。这真的很甜蜜。好吧，这会彻底击垮我。是的。哦，我喜欢这样。我不知道这个。你还好吗？是的。好吧，该死，我们怎么谈论别的事情？那太美了。我很抱歉。那太美了。我喜欢那是格雷格给出的方向。在那种方向下，这些时刻对我们来说变得非常真诚。
Yeah. And we all had little moments like that. That's a really big one, though. Well, there were those moments on the show that were surprises. Steve didn't know I was going to run up and tell him that basically that same thing, Steve, I'm going to miss you, you know, all the things that I said to him. Oscar didn't know the note that Jeff Blitz gave me. Yeah. So when all that emotion came, it was very, like, completely out of nowhere for him. Yeah. Okay.
是的。我们都有过这样的小时刻。不过，那真的是一个很大的时刻。好吧，节目中确实有一些惊喜的时刻。史蒂夫不知道我要跑过去告诉他，基本上就是同样的事情，史蒂夫，我会想念你的，你知道，我对他说过所有的话。奥斯卡不知道杰夫·布里茨给我的便条。是的。所以当所有的情绪涌上心头时，对他来说就像是完全空穴来风。是的。好的。
Well, geez, Louise. I'm sorry. That's okay. Where are we at in this episode? Well, we're at the moment when Kelly approaches Dwight in the kitchen. Kelly, that hussy. Oh, with her hair half down, half up. I know.
好吧，天哪。我很抱歉。没关系。我们在这一集的什么位置？嗯，我们正处于凯利在厨房接近德怀特的时刻。凯利，那个荡妇。哦，她的头发一半放下，一半扎起。我知道。
She goes up to my man and lays one on them. She does. And Angela sees it, and that is it. You know, a lot of people wrote in and commented that you're standing in front of a poster that says commitment. Am I really? Yes. Oh, my gosh. I didn't even notice that.
她走到我的男人面前，吻了他一下。她确实这么做了。安吉拉看到了，就是这样。你知道，很多人写信评论说你站在一张写着承诺的海报前面。我真的吗？是的。哦，天哪。我甚至没注意到。
That is so funny. I think I was just so focused on the scene. Wow. Yes. Angela loses it. Loses it. And this takes us outside. She's left the party. And now I have some stuff to tell you guys about this scene. All right. 20 minutes, 16 seconds. The ultimate Angela pissed offness has happened. So here's some behind the scenes of this scene. You have a guy up on the roof and he's got the soap snow that he's going to fall in your eyes. He's going to, yeah, it's stinging. And then there's snow on the ground because they've put real snow on the ground. We filmed this scene at the end of the day and everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougal, Randall Einhorn, and Mike Scher. So it was just kind of a skeleton crew at this point. Those are always some of my most favorite shoots. Yeah, me too.
太搞笑了。我想我当时太专注于那个场景了。哇。是的。安吉拉气疯了。气疯了。这把我们带到了外面。她已经离开了派对。现在我有一些关于这个场景的事情要告诉你们。好的。20分16秒。终极安吉拉暴躁时刻发生了。所以这里是这个场景的一些幕手花絮。房顶上有一个人，他手里拿着泡泡雪，会掉进你的眼睛里。他会，是的，刺痛。然后地上有雪，因为他们在地上铺了真雪。我们是在一天结束时拍摄这个场景的，所有人都走了。只有我和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔、兰德尔·艾恩霍恩和迈克·舍尔。所以此时此刻基本上是一个核心团队。这些一直是我最喜欢的拍摄之一。是的，我也是。
And we did not have a lot of time. We didn't have a lot of time to get this. The clock was ticking. Yeah, exactly, because we didn't want to go into overtime for everyone, and it was the end of the day. And so Charles McDougal said to me, we're probably only going to do like two takes, you know, maybe three. But they gave me these ornaments. And my instruction was that my character has just lost it. Michael has ruined Christmas.
而且我们没有太多时间。我们没有太多时间来完成这个。时间紧迫。是的，确切地说，因为我们不想让每个人都加班，而且那是天快黑的时候。所以查尔斯·麦克杜格尔对我说，我们大概只拍两遍，你知道，也许三遍。但他们给了我这些装饰品。我的指令是我的角色刚刚崩溃了。迈克尔毁了圣诞节。
Kelly has kissed my man. Ryan is the king of the party planning committee. Right? Yes. He said, I want you to take these ornaments and just throw them and shatter them. They were written in the script as glass ornaments. They were not glass ornaments. What?
凯利吻了我的男人。瑞安是派对策划委员会之王。对吧？是的。他说，我要你把这些装饰品拿走，然后扔掉并砸碎它们。剧本里写的是玻璃装饰品。它们不是玻璃装饰品。什么？
Watch the scene. I throw them down. They bounced straight up in the air. What were they? They were like some kind of plastic composite whatever. Oh, no. So when you look, watch it, you guys, you see them bounce in the air. I assumed, well, that makes sense.
看这个场景。我把它们扔下来。它们直接在空中弹起。它们是什么？它们就像某种塑料复合材料什么的。哦，不。所以当你看着，看着它，伙计们，你看到它们在空中弹跳。我以为，好吧，这说得通。
We did not have the budget to get special breakaway glass ornaments. And there's no way they would give you real glass. No. So these things bounced like a tennis ball. and so Charles is like cut and he goes okay two things one we need you to stand closer to the wall like if you can in the scene get as close to the wall as possible because that's where the guy is with the soap coming down yeah soap doesn't fall very far so we have another take and he's like why aren't you breaking the ornaments I'm like Charles they're bouncing what are you talking about
我们没有预算买特殊的易碎玻璃装饰品。他们绝不可能给你真正的玻璃。不。所以这些东西像网球一样弹了起来。所以查尔斯喊卡，他说，好吧，两件事，第一，我们需要你站得离墙更近一点，如果在场景中可以的话，尽可能靠近墙，因为那是拿肥皂的人下来的地方，是的，肥皂掉不了多远，所以我们再拍一次，他说，你为什么不砸碎装饰品？我说，查尔斯，它们在弹跳，你在说什么？
he goes can you throw them harder I was like yeah they're just going to bounce higher oh and I was like okay I got it I got it I have an idea so I know now we're really running out of time. So, and Michael Gallenberg had taken the most awesome photo that I have and it's the snow falling and me throwing the ornaments and Charles McDougal in the distance watching me. Oh, that's great. Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yeah, he took this photo. It was so cool. But anyway, here I am. We're running out of time. I got to stand. I got to get myself to the wall. I got to throw these ornaments and I need them to break. And I have to shriek, right? So I throw them with, I said, I'm going to throw them harder this time. I don't know. So I threw them as hard as I could.
他说，你能扔得更用力一点吗？我说，是的，它们只会弹得更高，哦，我说，好吧，我明白了，我明白了，我有一个主意，所以我现在知道我们真的时间不多了。所以，迈克尔·加伦伯格拍了我拥有过的最棒的照片，那是雪花落下，我扔着装饰品，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在远处看着我。哦，太棒了。迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的布景设计师。是的，他拍了这张照片。太酷了。不管怎样，我在这儿。我们时间不多了。我得站好。我得走到墙边。我得把这些装饰品扔出去，我需要它们碎掉。我得尖叫，对吧？所以我用力扔它们，我说，我这次要用力扔。我不知道。所以我尽我所能用力扔了它们。
They bounced up higher. I shrieked and I just started stomping on them and shattering them with my feet. Was that your intention going in when you're like, I have an idea. I can do it. I can do it. I was thinking if I can't get them to break, I have to start stopping on them. Yes. So that's what I just did. That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them. Folks, notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Oh, that's the perfect shoe for this. I know. And so I shrieked. I get to the wall. I'm stomping things. I ripped the box apart. We got the scene. Oh, let me tell you, Tone Loak 89 is going to be very happy because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that? One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film? All of that. Yes, exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene,
它们弹得更高了。我尖叫着，开始用脚踩它们并把它们踩碎。这是你进去时的意图吗，当你觉得，我有个主意。我能行。我能行。我在想，如果我无法让它们碎掉，我必须开始踩它们。是的。所以我刚才就是这么做的。那只是当时即兴发挥。我开始踩它们。各位，注意我穿的是我的辣妹鞋。哦，那是这个场景的最佳鞋子。我知道。所以我尖叫了。我走到墙边。我在踩东西。我把盒子撕碎了。我们拍好了这个场景。哦，让我告诉你，Tone Loak 89会非常高兴，因为他们写信提了一个粉丝问题。是什么？我最喜欢的场景之一是安吉拉尖叫并砸碎玻璃装饰品。拍摄感觉如何？所有这些。是的，完全正确。但如果你现在回去看这个场景，
you guys, watch like the first two that I throw. I think that's kind of from the first take. they bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides to go to poor Richards, Michael gets invited and the look on his face. It's better than any gift he could have been given. I know. And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk, this whole episode, and then you see this sort of sad, wounded person that just wants people to like him.
伙计们，看我扔的前两个。我想那大概是第一个镜头的。它们直接弹起来。所以当我们回到办公室时，我必须指出，当每个人都决定去穷人理查德酒吧时，迈克尔被邀请了，他脸上的表情。这比他能得到的任何礼物都好。我知道。这就是那种时刻，你会觉得，迈克尔在这一集里一直是个混蛋，然后你看到了这个有点悲伤、受伤的人，他只希望别人喜欢他。
Yes, how much he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like, he needs it. are he needs his gift to be the most popular. Yeah. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's Talking Head at the end where he's talking about Christmas and Gifts. Here's a little fun tidbit. This Talking Head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode.
是的，他多么需要别人邀请他去喝一杯。就像，他需要它。他需要他的礼物是最受欢迎的。是的。他需要那种接纳。好吧，我们在最后有迈克尔的单采，他谈到了圣诞节和礼物。这里有一个小有趣的趣闻。这个单采最初拍摄时是在这一集的开头。
Oh. But when they were editing, they put it at the end because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving, of us out in the snow in the parking lot. And he was like, oh, wait, that Talking Head. head. That works perfectly because something that we couldn't do because of the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song. No. You had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with song, but it's like the song playing in the car. Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is, what do they call that? Like a live sound. A live sound. Yeah, something like that. Active sound. Yeah. Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two
哦。但他们在剪辑时，把它放在了最后，因为格雷格想做一个蒙太奇，关于场景和人们离开，关于我们在雪地里在停车场。他说，哦，等等，那个单采。这太完美了，因为因为纪录片风格，我们无法做到的一些事情，你不能用一首歌做一个蒙太奇。不。蒙太奇是配合单采的。我们有一个带歌的蒙太奇，但就像在车里播放的歌。当然。诸如此类。它必须是声音，他们叫什么？像现场音。现场音。是的，诸如此类。活动音。是的。在我们进入节目的最后场景之前，我只想指出两个
lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode? Oh, yes. Say them. One is, happy birthday Jesus. Sorry, your party is so lame. Yes. And another fan favorite is Yankee swap is like Machiavelli meets Christmas. And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD deleted scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good. And you guys, Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy. I did a sketch show with him before the office years ago in my 20s. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on the office. But there is a scene in the deleted scenes where him and Creed move a desk and he gets
粉丝们引用的台词，作为这一集中他们有史以来最喜欢的台词之一？哦，是的。说出来。一个是，耶稣生日快乐。抱歉，你的派对太逊了。是的。另一个粉丝的最爱是洋基交换就像马基雅维利遇到圣诞节。我真的希望你们去看看这一集的DVD删减片段。顺便说一句，我们说这个没有拿钱。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。伙计们，奥斯卡·努涅斯在肢体喜剧方面太棒了。我在办公室之前的几年前在我的20多岁时和他一起做过一个素描秀。我们认识很久了。他是一个伟大的肢体喜剧演员，但他没有在办公室做太多这方面的事情。但是在删减片段中有一个场景，他和克里德搬了一张桌子，他被
pinned in by the desk. He has to get out from being stuck. And it's really, really funny. I want to see that. And Phyllis reveals in a deleted scene for this episode how she met Bob. Oh. She says that they met because he works next door. Oh, well, there you go. They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole rap. He wraps a whole portion of a song. So really check out these deleted scenes if you can. They're fantastic. All right. Let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right. It happens in Michael's office. He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office. takes off her top and then Steve as Michael takes a picture and then walks out
桌子夹住了。他必须从被困住的地方出来。真的非常非常搞笑。我想看那个。菲利斯在这一集的删减片段中透露了她是如何遇到鲍勃的。哦。她说他们相遇是因为他在隔壁工作。哦，好吧，那就对了。他们就在彼此旁边。凯文有一段完整的说唱。他唱了一首歌的整整一部分。所以如果可以的话，一定要去看看这些删减片段。它们太棒了。好了。我们来谈谈办公室里面的最后一个场景。好的。发生在迈克尔的办公室。他正准备离开。他要下楼去。梅雷迪思径直走进他的办公室。脱掉上衣，然后史蒂夫作为迈克尔拍了一张照片，然后走了出去
I have a fan question Well first of all Kate I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one I traded text with her but she is starting a tour
我有一个粉丝问题。好吧，首先，凯特，我真的很希望凯特能为这个打电话进来。我和她发了短信，但她要开始巡演
with Dancing with the Stars Oh yeah and she's traveling today She's on a plane and she called me night before last and she was like Angie I'm so sorry I can't come in
和与星共舞。哦，是的，她今天要出差。她在飞机上，前天晚上给我打电话，她说，安吉，非常抱歉，我不能来
but she was like I really do want to come in and talk about all things Meredith, so she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question. Okay. Carrie Shob said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said when characters flash each other,
但她说，我真的想来谈谈梅雷迪思的所有事情，所以她最终会来的。哦，那太好了。我有一种感觉，你可能知道这个粉丝问题的答案。好的。凯莉·肖布说，或者可能是凯莉·夏比，说当角色向对方闪光时，
are the actors really flashing each other in real life? No, no, no. No. I mean, sort of. Sort of. But no. I mean, it's still embarrassing. Even if I had to, like, be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward.
演员在现实生活中真的在互相闪光吗？不，不，不。不。我的意思是，某种程度上。某种程度上。但没有。我的意思是，仍然很尴尬。即使我必须，比如，穿泳衣，我也会觉得别扭。
You know what I mean? Kate was wearing pasty. Kate had things. She was kind of covered. Yeah, she had things over her hoo-haz. Yeah. Steve is such a gentleman. He said, Kate, I'm just going to look at like your neck. Yeah, I stare at your clavicle. They had no crew inside. Yep. Her image wasn't on any monitors anywhere. That's right. And there was no chip in the digital camera. So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that.
你知道我的意思吗？凯特穿着胸贴。凯特有东西。她基本上遮住了。是的，她的私处有东西盖着。是的。史蒂夫是个十足的绅士。他说，凯特，我只看你的脖子。是的，我盯着你的锁骨。他们里面没有剧组。是的。她的形象没有在任何地方的监视器上。没错。数字相机里没有芯片。所以闪光灯亮了。看起来迈克尔在拍照，但实际上从来没有拍过照片。从来没有照片。所以在照顾凯特这件事上，他们非常非常小心。
moment. Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes and quite a bit. Quite a bit. One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh my goodness. And all it said, this is her father who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania. And all it said was, Dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love Dad. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. What did Kate do? How did she respond to that? She was like, oh, man. Now, is that her dad having a sense of humor or is that him being like, seriously, stop it? I think both. I think both. All right. Should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here. Yes. Let's talk about the parking lot because it is definitely one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years. And we all say that. Yeah, people often ask, like, what were your favorite scenes? And it's always hard to explain because sometimes your favorite scene, it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes that make it your favorite. And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely. Definitely. Okay, so it's the end of the day. We have all of this real snow on the ground, and everyone is leaving, and everyone's in good spirits. And it's really nighttime. It was rare for us to ever work past. 6 p.m. So we always got excited. To walk out in the dark, I think, we all felt like we were up past
凯特后来作为梅雷迪思脱衣服脱了相当多。相当多。我最喜欢的事情之一是凯特的父亲写给她一封手写信。哦，天哪。上面只写着，这是她的父亲，你知道的，凯特来自宾夕法尼亚州。上面只写着，亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。爱你的爸爸。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯特做了什么？她是怎么回应的？她说，哦，天哪。现在，那是她父亲有幽默感还是他在说，说真的，停下来？我觉得两者都有。我觉得两者都有。好了。我们应该谈谈停车场吗？我们快说完了。是的。让我们谈谈停车场，因为这绝对是我在拍摄所有九年里记得的最神奇的时刻之一。我们都这么说。是的，人们经常问，比如，你最喜欢的场景是什么？这总是很难解释，因为有时你最喜欢的场景，看起来并不是那么激动人心的场景，但幕后发生的事情让你觉得它是最喜欢的。这个停车场场景就是其中之一。绝对的。绝对的。好的，所以是一天的结束。我们地上有所有这些真正的雪，每个人都要走了，每个人的精神都很好。真的是晚上了。我们很少工作超过。下午6点。所以我们总是很兴奋。走入黑暗中，我想，我们都觉得自己熬夜
our bedtime. But also, you have to remember, this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground. So this is magical in itself that we have a parking lot full of snow. And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know, like the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in, like the doors open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow and flung it at the other one. And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight. Yeah. And everyone loved it and they wanted us to keep doing it.
过了睡觉时间。而且，你必须记住，这是洛杉矶。地上从不下雪。所以这本身就很神奇，我们的停车场积满了雪。当我们走向汽车时，我不知道，就像你看到的镜头，我实际上在一辆SUV的前排乘客座位上，但我只进了一半，门是开着的。但我记得其中一个人抓了一些雪，向另一个人扔去。然后他们都开始抓雪，进行了一场即兴的打雪仗。是的。每个人都喜欢它，他们希望我们继续这样做。
But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. Yeah. And we turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it. Yeah. We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground. Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun.
但这就像我们所有人都在雪地里闲逛。是的。我们变成了一群孩子。我们情不自禁。是的。我们熬夜过了睡觉时间，地上有雪。地上有新雪。太有趣了。
And, you know, I have a picture of all of us. together in the parking lot with Charles McDougal, and it's great. I love it. I covet it. I love that. I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela. We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do. We need to compile and combine all of our stuff and then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Before we lose it all. We need to do it. Okay. It's 2020. We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it. Now I've got, like, Jenna's going to put me to task. This episode was really special. I really hope we did it justice because it means
而且，你知道，我有一张我们所有人在停车场和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在一起的照片，太棒了。我喜欢它。我垂涎三尺。我喜欢这样。我想看。是的。好吧，这就是为什么我们必须做我们的剪贴簿东西，安吉拉。我们会的。我们应该合并。好吧，这就是我们需要做的。我们需要汇编并合并我们所有的东西，然后把它做好，以便我们都能拥有我们都有的东西。是的。对吧？是的。在我们失去这一切之前。我们需要这样做。好的。现在是2020年。我们需要这样做。这是今年的目标。我为我们设定了今年的目标。好吧，伙计们，她说了。现在我有了，就像珍娜要监督我一样。这一集真的很特别。我真的希望我们没有辜负它，因为它对我们意义
so much to us. These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only, like, is it special to us personally, but it was like a big moment for our characters. Yeah. And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other, who are all getting to hang out. And we just happen to be on a TV show together. Yeah. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended. And that's really how it felt when we left this show. that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together
重大。这些集对我来说几乎比其他集更难，因为里面有太多的情感。场景中发生了太多事情。不仅，对我们个人来说很特殊，而且对我们的角色来说也是一个大时刻。是的。还有最后的那个时刻，那场打雪仗，那只是一群互相喜爱的人，都在一起闲逛。我们碰巧一起拍电视剧。是的。这真的是一个非常特别的时刻。我喜欢他们让它以这种方式结束。当我们离开这个节目时，感觉确实如此，我们只是一群碰巧一起拍电视剧的朋友
because we were friends. And we are friends. Yeah. And we're family. We are. So next week, we've got another big episode, Ann. Huge episode. I mean, listen, the rest of this season two
因为我们是朋友。我们是朋友。是的。我们是家人。我们是的。所以下周，我们还有另一个大集，安。巨大的集。我的意思是，听着，第二季剩下的部分
is just going to be one momentous episode after the other. Next up is Booze Cruise with our special guest, creator of the American Office, Greg Day. Daniels. Greg Daniels is going to be here. We are super excited. We cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Booth Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show, and
将是一个接一个重大的集。接下来是《酒类游轮》，我们的特别嘉宾，美国办公室的创造者格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格·丹尼尔斯要来了。我们超级兴奋。我们迫不及待地想跟他谈谈。提前谢谢你，格雷格。《酒类游轮》是一个非常非常大的集。我们下周见。拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·派弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关该节目的无广告版本和
our bonus episodes candy bag, go to stitcherpremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问 stitcherpremium.com。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 office。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。